THE IT'S A LITTLE BIT AFTER --
NINE THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
IS GOING TO START IN ABOUT A
MINUTE OR TWO WE'RE AS A
COURTESY.
WERE ALL THE DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS
A HERE AND WE WAITING FOR AT
LEAST ONE OF OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES AS A COURTESY --
IF NOT WE'RE GOING TO BE AGAIN
SO THAT WE DON'T HOLD EVERYONE
UP
[inaudible]
OKAY
.
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC.
IT'S NOW BEEN ADJOURNED --
IN SESSION --
MA'AM SECTOR CALL THE ROLL JONES
SAWYER HERE LACKEY [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK HERE SANTIAGO.
WICKS.
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
THE FOLLOWING TWO BILLS HAVE
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHORS --
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB FOR THREE
THREE RAMOS POLL BY AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FIVE OH
THREE FLORA.
ALSO PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
WE ALSO HAVE --
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR --
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THREE NINE
SEVEN CHAO VEHICLES DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE CANNABIS --
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB FOUR THREE
NINE STONE JUVENILES COMPETENCY.
URGENCY. EIGHT ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB FIVE ONE SEVEN CHEN ORANGE
COUNTY PROPERTY CRIME TASK FORCE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB FIVE TWO
FOUR BIGELOW PEACE OFFICERS
DEPUTY SHERIFF'S ITEM NUMBER TEN
AB. FIVE EIGHT ONE LEVINE
SENTENCING MEMBERS OF MILITARY
TRAUMA.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB FIVE NINE
SEVEN LEVINE PROBATION AND
MANDATORY SUPERVISION BLAST
INCARCERATION.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB SIX OH
THREE MELINDA'S FIREARMS RETIRED
PEACE OFFICERS.
AND FINALLY ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
SIX ONE ONE NAZARIAN --
SEXUAL ABUSE OF ANIMALS --
MOTION TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CAL.
CALL THE ROLL.
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY.
BAUER-KAHAN HI BAUER-KAHAN I
DEEP [inaudible]
I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
WICKS HI WICKS I THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN APPROVED.
AND WILL GO. TO REGULAR BUSINESS.
MISTER.
PATTERSON SIGNED IN JUST MAKING
SURE IS NOT THE ROOM.
THEN IT'S UP MISTER CHOI --
ITEM.
AB [inaudible]
FOR FIVE FIVE ME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR.
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB FULL
FOUR FIVE OF WHICH WOULD PROVIDE.
FOR UP TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS OFF OF A REIMBURSE
MONTEL CRIME VICTIM SO FOR LEGAL
TO SUPPORT.
MáS IS THE LAW THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIMS ARE RIGHT OF A BILLABLE
RIGHT SO WHICH PASSED IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT PROVIDES A
CRIME VICTIM SO WITH THE
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED THE
RIGHTS.
MáS IS A LAW LISA SEVENTEEN
ENUMERATED OF RIGHTS INCLUDING A
RIGHT TO HAVE.
REPRESENTATION THROUGHOUT THE U.
COURT JUSTICE PROCESS.
HOWEVER CURRENTLY VICTIMS I HAVE
TO HIRE AND THE PAY FOR THEIR
OWN ATTORNEY ALTHOUGH MANY DO
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO PAY
FOR IT BECOMES A RIGHTS ATTORNEY.
THE CALIFORNIA VICTIMS ARE
COMPENSATION PROGRAM CAVS V. C.
B..
COVERS ALL COSTS UP TO A CERTAIN
AMOUNT FOR MEDICAL EXPENSES
FUNERAL AND BURIAL MANY OF THE
SERVICES AND THE SUPPORT.
HOWEVER CURRENTLY YEAH THEY DO
FEES SO FOR ONE ATTORNEY.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE FOR UP
TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
OFF OF REIMBURSEMENT THE VICTIM
SO FOR LEGAL SUPPORT.
A VICTIM SO RIGHT SO TONY IS SAW
HELP. FOR TO VICTIMS OF FOR
CLARIFICATION OF OUR MOST IS THE
LAW AND THE FOR REPRESENTATION
DURING THE COURT PROCESS ARE AND
THE THROUGHOUT THE LEGAL PROCESS.
THE NEED FOR SUCH AN WOULD EXIST.
FOR BAIL HEARINGS.
ELIMINAR YOU TRY EL TRY OTHERS
AND THE THE PROCEDURE OR
INSTANCES.
THIS COST IS SOUGHT TO BE.
PART OF THE RESTITUTION PAID
BACK TO THE STATE.
BY THE OFFENDER.
WITH ME TODAY TO GIVE A
TESTIMONY AS DON QUIXOTE DE OF
FROM CRIME VICTIM SO UNITED. TO
GIVE MORE DETAILS ABOUT THE A.
B..
FOUR FOUR FIVE THANK YOU MISTER.
REMEMBER THANK YOUR ACCOUNT ON
CAP HERE MCCUE CAP CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
AS THE ASSEMBLYMAN MENTIONED --
MARCY'S LAW OUT PROPOSITION NINE
PASSED BY THE VOTERS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT DID A FOR CRIME
VICTIMS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
FOR REPRESENTATION TO BE HEARD --
AND MUCH MORE PROCESS --
THAT SAID YOU KNOW --
THERE IS IN EQUITY IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROCESS WHEREBY --
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES AND AND
FOR DEFENDANTS TO BE PROVIDED
STATE PAID COUNSEL AT THROUGHOUT
THAT PROCESS WERE AS VICTIMS
UNLESS THEY'RE ABLE TO AFFORD
THAT THEMSELVES.
I DON'T HAVE SOMEONE ACTING
SOLELY ON THEIR BEHALF --
AND SO BY A BEFORE FOUR FIVE
WOULD AUTHORIZE ARE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR VICTIM
REIMBURSEMENT FOR COUNSEL TO
HELP SUPPORT THEIR NEEDS THEIR
REPRESENTATION SPECIFICALLY --
THROUGHOUT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
JUSTICE PROCESS NO CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED IN PARTICULAR WORKS VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS OUT TO REPRESENT.
A VICTIMS --
BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD ON
PAROLE DECISIONS AND WE'VE SEEN
A NUMBER OF TIMES WHERE THE
VICTIM IS NOT NECESSARILY BAN --
RIGHTFULLY AFFORDED --
THEIR FULL OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HEARD -- AND
EVEN IN SOME CASES ARE WHERE
THEY THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS COMMISSIONER IS EVEN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT IS AFFORDED TO
VICTIMS.
OF THIS BILL AB FOUR FOUR FIVE
WOULD HELP PROVIDE.
AN EQUITY --
IN THE SYSTEM SUCH THAT A
SIMILAR TO DEFENDANT'S BE
PROVIDED STATE PAID COUNSEL ARE
VICTIMS WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT OF FOUR
REPRESENTATION LEGALLY ON THEIR
BEHALF AS WELL.
WE THINK THIS IS AN EQUITABLE
HOW CONSIDERATION ON AND WOULD
APPRECIATE RIFLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NAY.
MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING CATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
THE KIND OF COMPENSATION
PROPOSED UNDER A BEFORE FORTY
FIVE IS UNLIKE ANY OTHER
PROVIDED TO VICTIMS THROUGH THE
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD.
OTHER COMPENSATION COMPENSATE
VICTIMS FOR HARMS THAT DIRECTLY
FLOW FROM THE CRIME FOR EXAMPLE
MEDICAL EXPENSES COUNSELING
EXPENSES --
COMPENSATION FOR LOSS OF INCOME.
PAYING OF VICTIMS' ATTORNEYS
FEES COMPENSATES THAT PERSON FOR
A CHOICE AS TO HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO ENGAGE IN THE CRIMINAL
TO WITH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM --
WHERE THAT PERSON HAS MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS TO ASSERT --
HIS OR HER RIGHTS --
SUCH AS ASKING THE ASSISTANCE OF
THE PROSECUTING ATTORNEY WITH
WITH PUTTING WITH ASSERTING
THOSE RIGHTS --
OR SEEKING HELP FROM A VICTIMS
SERVING THOSE RIGHTS ON HIS OR
HER OWN BEHALF --
THERE ARE MANY RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO VICTIMS --
TO INFORM THEM OF THOSE RIGHTS
AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY --
IS REQUIRED TO HELP THEM --
PRESERVE THOSE RIGHTS UPON
REQUEST --
MAKING NEW SOURCES OF MONEY
AVAILABLE FOR PRIVATE ATTORNEYS
WILL ENCOURAGE VICTIMS TO HIRE
ATTORNEYS --
EVEN WHEN THAT IS NOT NEEDED AND
MAY NOT BE THE BEST WAY TO
ASSERT THEIR RIGHTS --
EVEN AN ATTORNEY WHO IS.
PUTTING THE SYSTEM COMPLETELY
ETHICALLY OF COURSE HAS SOME.
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE --
TO WANT TO SHOW UP AT MORE
HEARINGS WANT.
WANT THE VICTIM TO BE MORE OF A
PARTICIPANT AND IN THE PROCESS --
EVEN WHEN THAT MAY NOT BE THE
RIGHT CHOICE FOR THE PARTICULAR
VICTIM OR WHERE THOSE RIGHT
WHERE THE VICTIMS PARTICIPATION
COULD HAVE BEEN ACCOMPLISHED.
OTHERWISE --
THE END RESULT WILL BE TO TILT
THE BALANCE OF COURT PROCEEDINGS
NOT IN FAVOR OF THE ACTUAL
PARTICULAR INTERESTS OF EACH
INDIVIDUAL VICTIM.
BUT TOWARDS THE ROAD APPROACH
THAT WILL RESULT IN A GREATER
USE OF PRIVATE COUNSEL IN A
SYSTEM THAT --
THAT NOW HAS --
OTHER OPTIONS AVAILABLE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MARCO GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
GOOD MORNING --
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSES A. B. --
FOUR FOUR FIVE BECAUSE IT IS
UNNECESSARY VICTIMS RIGHTS ARE
ALREADY PROTECTED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION ARTICLE
ONE SECTION.
TWENTY EIGHT EN COUNTY
PROSECUTORS WHO DO THEIR JOB
WITHOUT THE PROFIT MOTIVE --
INCENTIVIZE STE BY THIS BILL
ENSURE THAT VICTIMS RECEIVE
THOSE RIGHTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A VICTIM IS
ALREADY ENTITLED TO RECOVER
ATTORNEY FEES AS PART OF A
CRIMINAL RESTITUTION.
PROVIDED THAT THOSE FEES ARE
BOTH REASONABLE AND WE'RE SPENT
RECOVERING FOR AN ACTUAL LOSS
SUFFERED BY THE VICTIM.
THIS CAREFUL BALANC ALLOWS
VICTIMS TO OBTAIN LEGAL
ASSISTANCE WORDS NECESSARY TO
RECOVER FROM AN ACTUAL LOSS.
AND WE BELIEVE AB FOUR OR FIVE
IS BAD POPUP PUBLIC POLICY
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES AN INCENTIVE.
FOR SOME UNSCRUPULOUS LAWYERS TO
DRAG OUT THE CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS IN ORDER TO SEEK
MORE MONEY UNDER THE GUISE OF
DOING.
THE WORK THAT'S ACTUALLY ALREADY
DONE IN MOST JURISDICTIONS
BETTER AND MORE EFFICIENTLY BY
COUNTY PROSECUTORS.
AND MOST LARGE --
OF COUNTIES HAVE --
VICTIMS WITNESS ASSISTANCE UNITS.
THAT APPEAR IN COURT WITH THE
VICTIMS WHEN THEY'RE REQUESTED.
TO THEY SPEND TIME TALKING TO
THE VICTIMS ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS.
AND THEY NOTIFY THE VICTIMS WHEN
THERE'S GOING TO BE A COURT
HEARING WHAT'S GOING TO BE
EXPECTED OF THEM --
THEY HELP THEM IF THEY WISH
PREPARE THEY CAN --
MAKE AT SENTENCING OR AT ANY
OTHER POINT IN THE PROCEEDINGS
EXCEPT YOU KNOW THE CTUAL
TOMORROW WHILE THEY'RE
TESTIFYING.
AND IF THE VICTIMS OR FEELING
COMFORTABLE ON GIVING THE
STATEMENTS THEMSELVES.
THE VICTIM WITNESS ADVOCATE FOR
THE PROSECUTOR WILL READ THE
STATEMENT.
SO THIS IS WORK THAT IS ALREADY
PAID FOR IT'S ALREADY BEING DONE.
AB FOUR FOUR FIVE SIX JUST TO
TRANSFORM TRANSFORM MORE MONEY.
FROM THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION.
FUND TWO LAWYERS WHO ARE NOT
NEEDED.
IN THIS --
SCHEME OF THINGS.
AND THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND AS URINALYSIS ALREADY SHOWS
IS SERIOUSLY BEING DEPLETED.
THIS WOULD BE AN ADDED EXPENSE.
THAT WOULD ULTIMATELY BE BORNE
BY THE EITHER THE TAXPAYERS
VICTIMS OR INDIGENT DEFENDANTS.
WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK
YOU OPPOSITION.
WITH THAT ARE YOU ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OF THE CALLER REPLIED YES MISTER
LACKEY YEAH I I THINK --
I'M I'M CLEARLY GOING TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL DAY.
BUT THE DEFENSE DOES HAVE A VERY
GOOD POINT ABOUT THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION FUND WHICH IS NOT
PRIMARILY YOUR PROBLEM AT BUT
OUR PROBLEM.
BECAUSE IT IS DEPLETING AND
CUTTING OFF ITS SOURCE OF INCOME
TO BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT --
IT'S UNFAIR TO PENALIZE PEOPLE
FISCALLY BUT WE HAVE TO FIND
SOME SOURCE.
A FUNDING FOR THIS VICTIMS A
COMPENSATION FUND.
SO IT IS A LEGITIMATE THING THAT
I THINK WE NEED TO WORK THROUGH.
AND THIS IS NOT A FISCAL
COMMITTEE THIS A POLICY
COMMITTEE SO CLEARLY I'M GOING
TO BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
OKAY.
POSTED IN YOU MAY CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
THANK YOU AB FOUR FOUR FIVE IS --
SIMPLY --
SEEKING TO ELIMINATE THE
LOOPHOLE.
EXISTING IN MáS IS LAW.
YES AVE TIM'S CAN RETAIN A TONY
SERVICES THAT ARE ALREADY
APPROVED.
AND THE BE GIVEN EQUAL ACCESS SO
REGARDLESS OF A FINANCIAL
BACKGROUND.
UP TO THE LEGAL SERVICES THIS IS
SAW ARE NOT PRECEDING SELF BUT
THIS HAS A SIMPLY HOW BRITISH
SOFT VICTIMS OF UP TO PROTECT
THAT THEY ARE RIGHT SO.
OF FULLY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI FOR
BRINGING THIS ON CHAIRS
RECOMMENDING AND NO --
IT'S IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING
WHEN YOU HAVE LAWYERS.
SAYING LAWYERS ARE GETTING PAID
TOO MUCH IT'S THIS --
KIND OF PERPLEXING SOMETIMES --
BUT MR LACKEY IS ABOUT A POINT
ABOUT THE VICTIMS OF SYSTEM --
COMPENSATION FUN BEING DEPLETED
AND THEN DIVERTING THAT MONEY --
FROM VICTIMS TWO ATTORNEYS I
KNOW THIS SOUNDS LIKE A MEANS OF
PROGRAMS OUT ANTI ATTORNEY BUT
DID TO DIVERT MORE.
OF THOSE RESOURCES AWAY FROM THE
VICTIMS WHO MAY NEED --
MONIES.
FOR ECONOMIC REASONS FOR A
MENTAL HEALTH --
AND YOU KNOW WHEN A TRAGEDY
HAPPENS THERE'S A MYRIAD OF
OTHER THINGS THAT THEY THAT THEY
WILL NEED AND IT IT'S THIS IS
DIFFICULT TO DIVERT.
ANY OF THE LAST DEPLETING
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVEN'T
VICTIMS ASSISTANCE FUND --
OVER -- TO
ATTORNEYS AND I THINK WE DO NEED
TO FIX THE SYSTEM.
IF THE IF THE D. A.'S ARE NOT
DOING THEIR JOB OF ENSURING THAT
YOU CAN YOU CAN BE THERE AT
HEARINGS YOU CAN PROVIDING YOU
THE ASSISTANCE THAT YOU NEED AND
YOU MEANING --
VICTIMS OF OF THE THEN WE NEED
TO DO A BETTER JOB AT KEEPING
THEM ENSURING THAT THAT THAT
THEY DO THAT AND THAT WE WE DO
THAT AND SO MAYBE IN ANOTHER
CONVERSATION.
AND ANOTHER TYPE OF LEGISLATION
WE CAN WE CAN TALK ABOUT DOING
THAT BECAUSE THAT IS MORE
PERMANENT.
THAT IS SOMETHING ALL THE THINGS
THAT THE SOME WOMEN MENTION --
GAPS IN THE SYSTEM A LOT OF IT
IS WE JUST IMPROVE THE SYSTEM --
WILL BE ABLE TO ALLEVIATE SOME
OF THE PAIN ON THE VICTIMS OF
CRIME.
AND SO WITH THAT THE JUDGE
RECOMMEND UNLIKE LOCATION.
MY PROJECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
ON A BEFORE FORTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JOHN SO YOU'RE NOW LACKEY.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN NOT VOTING DEEP.
HI.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE NO
KAMLAGER-DOVE HAVE NO QUIRK.
NO QUIRK NELL SANTIAGO.
WICKS NO WICKS NOW.
I'M SORRY THE MEASURE FAILS
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE THE
MATTER TO THE TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WILK. TO PATTERSON STILL IS NOT
HERE SO WE'LL GO TO MISCARRY --
TO A
WHEN EVER YOU READY
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
WANTS TO SIT WITH ME
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU THAT'S THE SIGN.
I AM I AM SO HAPPY TO BE WITH
YOU ALL HERE THIS MORNING I I
MISSED THIS COMMITTEE SO IT'S
NICE IT'S NICE TO BE BACK.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE STAFF I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB.
SIX OH SEVEN A MODEST BUT
IMPORTANT REFORM TO OUR CURRENT
SENTENCING AND JUDICIAL
PRACTICES.
AB SIX OH SEVEN IS THE RE
INTRODUCTION OF SB TEN TWENTY
FIVE FROM SENATOR SKINNER WHICH
PASSED THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
SENATOR SKINNER AND I ARE
WORKING ON THIS BILL AGAIN --
THIS YEAR SHE IS THE CO AUTHOR
ALONG WITH SENATOR MITCHELL
WIENER BRADFORD AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK. FOR CERTAIN NON
SERIOUS AND NON VIOLENT DRUG
OFFENSES CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS
JUDGES TO EVALUATE ALL THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE CASE AND
APPLY THEIR DISCRETION.
IN SENTENCING. FOUR ZERO CURRENT
LAW PROHIBITS JUDGES TO EVALUATE
ALL THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
CASE AND APPLIED THEIR
DISCRETION.
IN SENTENCING INSTEAD EIGHT
JUDGE IS FORCED TO CHARGE AND
INCARCERATE A PERSON WHO WOULD
BE BETTER TREATED AND SUPERVISED.
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES UNDER
PROBATION.
AB SIX OR SEVEN ALLOWS JUDGES TO
USE DISCRETION IN ORDER --
TO TO ALLOW PROBATION SERVICES
FOR OFFENSES THAT CURRENTLY
MANDATE INCARCERATION IN COUNTY
JAILS AND STATE PRISONS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT.
BY CHANGE SENTENCING STRUCTURE
OR AFFECT MAXIMUM SENTENCES
UNDER.
SIX OH SEVEN JUDGES WILL STILL
CHOOSE TO SEND INDIVIDUALS TO
PRISON OR JAIL BUT THIS BILL
ALLOWS JUDGES TO WEIGH IN THE
FAX.
AND USE OTHER AVENUES OTHER
METHODS TO ACHIEVE JUSTICE.
PROBATION PROVIDE THE SERVICES
UP PROVIDE SERVICES SUCH AS
EFFECTIVE DRUG DRUG TREATMENTS
THAN NOT THEY MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE IN COUNTY JAILS WHICH
WE KNOW IS CURRENTLY.
UNAVAILABLE THERE IS AN
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
CONSENSUS TO MANDATORY MINIMUM
SENTENCES FOR DRUG OFFENSES --
AND WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS
NEXT TOWARD --
WOULDN'T WITH THE APPELLATE
ATTORNEY HE'S AN APPELLATE
ATTORNEY WITH THE ONLY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
GENET SAID SAID FUNNY BUT BEING
FUNNY BUT THEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE THE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE DIRECTOR FOR
THE DRUG POLICY AND THE ELEVATOR
CENTER.
MOVE THE BILL.
I THANK YOU NEXT ORDER NUMBER
YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NEXT ROAD
WITH THE LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THIS
REFORM.
AND WITH THE TIME I HAVE I I
JUST WANTED TO AND TRY TO PUT A
FACE ON WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
I MYSELF HAVE REPRESENTED A
NUMBER OF CLIENTS HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY THE CURRENT LAW.
AND CURRENT LAW ESSENTIALLY SAYS
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE A PRE
EXISTING DRUG CONVICTION YOU
HAVE A NEW DRUG CONVICTION THE
JUDGE IS NOT ALLOWED TO PUT YOU
ON PROBATION.
EVEN WHEN THE JUDGE CONCLUDES
IT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
COMMUNITY THE DEFENDANT AND
EVERYONE ELSE THAT HE'D HERE SHE
DO SO. ONE OF MY CLIENTS WHO
WILL CALL AMY AM FIRST BECAME IN
MASH THE COMMODE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AT THE TENDER AGE OF TWELVE HER
MOTHER ALSO A DRUG USER --
HAD TWELVE YEAR OLD AMY HELPER
INJECT HEROIN BECAUSE HER
MOTHER'S VEINS HAD COLLAPSED --
MY TWELVE YEAR OLD THAN CLIENT
WAS REQUIRED TO INJECT.
THE VEINS IN HER MOTHER'S
GROWING AND ASK YOU TAKE JUST A
MINUTE AND THINK ABOUT YOUR OWN
CHILDREN IMAGINE THAT KIND OF
LIFE FOR A KID.
THAT TIME I HAD A ME AS A CLIENT
SHE WAS IN HER ACTIONS BEHIND
HER.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYBODY IN
THIS ROOM WHO THINKS IF AMY WAS
WILLING TO ACCEPT TREATMENT AND
A JUDGE THOUGHT THAT SHE WAS
APPROPRIATE THAT THAT JUDGE
SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED TO DIRECT.
AMY INTO TREATMENT AND UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW THE JUDGE WAS NOT
AND I BELIEVE THAT COMMITTEE
WITH THIS AT THIS --
BODIES OWN AND NOT ANALYST
INDICATES THAT CURRENTLY
INCARCERATING PEOPLE LIKE ME
COST THE CITY CALIFORNIA EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR --
TO PUT IT ANOTHER WAY IF WE KEEP
TO AMY'S OUT OF CUSTODY WE CAN
PUT A KID THROUGH A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE --
EVERY TIME WE DO IT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING --
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JEANETTE CITY BY CLEAN
I'M AN ATTORNEY AND THE STATE
DIRECTOR. FOR THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE I AM HERE ALSO --
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
OF SEVEN AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED THEIR STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AT THAN AT
THE NATIONAL LEVEL. TO GET RID
OF MANDATORY MINIMUMS AND AS YOU
HEARD MY COLLEAGUE HERE NEXT
SPEAK ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
TO GIVE JUDGES --
THE JUDICIAL DISCRETION IN TERMS
OF ALLOWING FOLKS TO LIKE HEALTH
MORE -- AT
DIGNITY CENTERED FOCUSED --
PERSPECTIVE AND SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR THOSE
REASONS --
THE OTHER THING I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT OBVIOUSLY IS THAT FROM
DRUG POLICIES PERSPECTIVE --
WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
A RACIAL AND A CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE.
WE KNOW THAT THE WAR ON DRUGS
HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY HARD
HITTING ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY BLACK AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES --
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE REALLY.
BELIEVE THAT GIVING JUDGES THE
DISCUSSION --
TO OUT.
DO ALTERNATIVE SENTENCING IN IN
IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS OR HAVE
THAT DISCRETION --
WOULD HELP REDUCE THE THE IMPACT
THAT THE WAR ON DRUGS HAS HAD ON
ON THESE COMMUNITIES --
AND THEN JUST REALLY QUICKLY --
TO COOK MICHELLE ALEXANDER ON
THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW JIM CROW --
NOTHING HAS CONTRIBUTED MORE
PEOPLE OF COLOR S. --
DRUGS AND AS MENTIONED EARLIER
WELL SO THAT --
INCARCERATING INDIVIDUALS IS
VERY COSTLY BOTH AT THE STATE
AND THE FEDERAL LEVEL --
AS NICK MENTIONED JUST
INCARCERATING SOMEONE FOR THREE
YEARS COSTS --
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS --
AND WE AS A SOCIETY COULD DO
BETTER IN TERMS OF REALLY
LOOKING AT FOLKS --
AND AT MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK IS FOR
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS A DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION.
MARGOT GEORGE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT HERNANDEZ WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
WHERE SECOND SALAS ON BEHALF OF
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU?
CAN MORE UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS
ASK ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YES SELECT.
THANK YOU I I DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE MANY PARTS OF THIS --
PROPOSAL THAT ARE SUPPORTABLE
BUT I THERE THERE'S A PART OF IT
IT'S A VERY VERY PERPLEXING TO
ME IN.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE IT MAKES MUCH
BEGUN SENSE. TO ALLOW JUVENILE
AS A CRIMINAL HISTORY OF SELLING
OR POSSESSING LARGE QUANTITIES
OF COCAINE TO OWNER PROCESS A
FIREARM.
AT AGE TWENTY ONE STIFF.
THIRTY CURRENT LAW SAYS IT WOULD
BE.
THIRTY YOUR THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
MAKE IT.
MAKE INELIGIBLE TO OWN A FIREARM
EARLIER.
I THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM.
OF THIS TIME LIMIT OF DO YOU
WANNA.
YOU WANT TO DRESS IN YOUR
CLOSING ADDRESS IT NOW ALL
ADDRESS IT NOW UP MISTER LIKE I
DON'T THINK THAT'S A THAT'S OUR
BILL.
WELL YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH
THAT BUT IT.
STRIKES RIGHT HERE --
IN AB SIX OR SEVEN SUBSECTION
ONE SUBSECTION BE.
IT SAYS OF SEVEN OF SECTOR SEVEN
OH SEVEN OF THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS COLD.
AN OFFENSE DESCRIBED IN
SUBSECTION BE OF TWELVE OR
TWENTY AT TWELVE OH THREE POINT.
OH SEVEN THREE ANY OFFENSE
ENUMERATED AND BLAH BLAH BLAH IS
STRICKEN AND THAT IS.
THE PROVISION I JUST OUTLINED.
WELCOME BACK TO ON THE OKAY
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
I'M.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL --
FORWARD I WILL BE THEM
SUPPORTING AND I THINK WE SHOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT MORE WAYS TO
OFFER DIVERSIONARY OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OUR JUDGES. TO CONSIDER --
I CERTAINLY THINK WE SHOULD ALSO
BE ENCOURAGING MORE JUDICIAL US
DISCRETION RECOGNIZING OF COURSE
THAT THERE'S WORK TO BE DONE IN
ALL AREAS OF PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH IMPLICIT
SURE THAT SENTENCING.
THE YOU KNOW ALSO SORT OF
RECOGNIZES THAT BUT HAVING SAID
THAT I THINK THIS IS ONE STEP
CLOSER TOWARDS UNWINDING THE JIM
CROW ERA LAWS THAT HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED POOR
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF COLOR FOR
DECADES NOW SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU YES MISTER I CONSUMERS.
FOR ALL RIGHT --
SO OBVIOUSLY IN VOTING FOR THIS
IS A CO AUTHOR.
OF WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO RISK
TO TAKE A LOOK AT MR --
LACKEY.
YEAH I KNOW.
MR LACKEYS OBJECTION AND SEE IF
YOU CAN'T GET.
IF IT'S TRUE THAT YOU WOULD
ALLOW SOMEBODY TO HAVE A GUN
AFTER THOSE.
CONVICTIONS WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND SAY
MAYBE THEY COULD NEVER GONE.
ABSOLUTELY OKAY THANK YOU.
DID YOU.
GO OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU WELL WE
ABSOLUTELY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT --
WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE WHEN
IT COMES TO JUDICIAL DISCRETION.
IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR
CONGRESS PASSED AND THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED THE FIRST STEP
TACK INCLUDING AN EXPANSION OF
COURT DISCRETION FOR MANDATORY
MINIMUMS AND A REDUCTION IN
SENTENCING IT'S FOR DRUG
OFFENSES.
SO THERE IS A NATIONAL HAVE AN
A. B. SIX OH SEVEN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CAN CERTAINLY PAVE
THE WAY FOR THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU --
CHAIRS RECOMMENDED AYE AND FROM
THE LOOK ON YOUR FACE AND YOUR
SUPPORTERS WHEN MR LACKEY
MENTIONED --
WHEN YOU MENTION TO YOU YOU'RE
TAKEN BY SURPRISE --
THE SO I I KNOW YOU YOU THAT WAS
NOT YOUR INTENT NOTED ON ON
EITHER SIDE AND SO --
HOPEFULLY THIS IS ALSO --
A LESSON TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
WANNA GO AROUND THE POLICY
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THAT THIS IS THE REASON WE HAVE
POLICY COMMITTEE SO WE CAN FLUSH
THOSE THINGS ALSO THINGS THAT
MAKE FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WE HAVE SOME VERY SMART PEOPLE
SPECIAL PUBLIC SAFETY THAT CAN.
SEE THAT AND WE CAN MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE --
CORRECTIONS BEFORE IT HITS THE
FLOOR SO --
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS WHEN IT
WORKS AND SO I'M I'M.
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AND I
BASED ON HOW YOUR REACTION BUT
THE REACTION OF THE THE THE THE
ADVOCATES FOR THIS AND SO
CHAIRED RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible] EIGHT EXCUSE ME AN
EIGHTY SIX OR SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BAUER-KAHAN HI
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
BILL DEEP NOW KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
WICKS HI WICKS I THE MEASURE
PASSES.
AND MISTER PATTERSON ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AB FIVE EIGHT TWO I SHOULD
ITEM NUMBERS.
NUMBER ELEVEN ANDI.
BUT NUMBER ONE IN MY HEART.
THANK YOU OUT.
A MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY OF
PRESENTING AB.
FIVE EIGHT TWO GAVIN'S LAW THIS
BILL HAS BEEN NAMED FOR GAVIN
GLADDING.
A BELOVED VICE PRINCIPAL FROM
CLOVIS.
WHO WAS TRAGICALLY HIT AND
KILLED IN THE EARLY MORNING
HOURS?
WHILE HE WAS OUT FOR A RUN LAST
SEPTEMBER --
GAVIN WAS A HUSBAND A FATHER A
PASSIONATE EDUCATOR.
A FORMER PEACE CORPS VOLUNTEER.
HE WAS BELOVED BY ALL WHO KNEW
HIM.
THE DRIVER WHO KILLED GAVIN.
DID NOT STOP [inaudible] TO HELP.
EVEN AS GAVIN LAY THERE CLINGING
TO LIFE THE DRIVER FLED THE
SCENE.
EVIDENCE DEMONSTRATED THAT THIS
DRIVER WAS DRINKING HEAVILY AT A
PARTY JUST HOURS BEFORE.
THE HIT AND RUN.
BECAUSE HE FLED THE SCENE.
AND WAS NOT CAUGHT FOR FIVE DAYS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS COULD
NOT PROVE HE WAS DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE.
RIGHT NOW IN CURRENT LAW.
THERE IS A PERVERSE LOOPHOLE.
WHICH ENCOURAGES ACTUALLY
REWARDS DRIVERS. TO FLEE THE
SCENE OF AN ACCIDENT.
NOT TO STAY [inaudible]
AND HELP [inaudible]
BY FLEEING.
THEY CAN PURPOSEFULLY AVOID
ADDITIONAL CHARGES. FOR HIT AND
RUN.
AND FOR DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE.
THE MAXIMUM SENTENCE FOR A HIT
AND RUN [inaudible]
INVOLVING DEATH.
IS FOUR YEARS.
THE MAN WHO KILLED GAVIN WAS
SENTENCED TO THREE YEARS HE WILL
SERVE [inaudible] EIGHTEEN
MONTHS.
THIS SHORT SENTENCE ACTUALLY
REWARDS THE DRIVER FOR LEAVING
THE SCENE.
AND FOR LEAVING GAVIN UNDER
UNTENDED AND STRUGGLING TO STAY
ALIVE.
WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH AB?
FOR FIVE EIGHTY TWO IS TO SEE TO
IT THAT THE PENALTIES FOR
LEAVING THE SCENE OF AN ACCIDENT.
WHICH RESULTS IN DEATH OR GREAT
BODILY INJURY.
BY MAKING THESE PENALTIES.
GREATER THAN THE PENALTY FOR A
D. Y. AND BRINGING THEM IN LINE.
WITH THE VEHICLE VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
REALLY CHANGE?
WHAT IS?
ESSENTIALLY SORT OF A PERVERSE.
CULTURE WITH RESPECT TO HIT.
AND RUN.
WE WANT TO LET DRIVERS KNOW
CLEARLY.
THAT IF THEY HIT.
HURT.
KEEP A KILL AND RUN.
THEY WILL FACE AS MUCH OR MORE
TIME THEN IF THEY STAY.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WAS GAVIN'S
WIFE SUSAN.
AND RANDY PERRY REPRESENTING THE
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
A RESEARCH ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
YES.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SUSAN GLADDING AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF CLOVIS CALIFORNIA
AND FRESNO COUNTY.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO AND KNOWN AS GAVIN'S
Là.
ON THE MORNING OF SEPTEMBER
SIXTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN MY
LIFE IS CHANGED FOREVER
[inaudible]
MY HUSBAND.
BEST FRIEND AND FATHER OF MY TWO
CHILDREN GO INCLUDING WAS STOLEN
FROM US BY RECKLESS DRIVER.
AND THE DRIVERS REPORTEDLY HAVE
BEEN DRINKING.
IN THE EARLY HOURS OF SEPTEMBER
SIXTEENTH.
WHO DIDN'T HAVE A DRIVER'S
LICENSE GOT INTO HIS PARENTS
TRUCK LOST CONTROL OF THE
VEHICLE AND SWERVED INTO MY
HUSBAND WHO IS DRIVING ALONG
SIDE FRIED ROAD AND FRESNO?
KEVIN SEVERED MAJOR INJURIES
FROM THE COLLISION AND WITH LEFT
DYING ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD AS
THE DRIVER FLED THE SCENE.
HE DID NOT HAVE THE DECENCY TO
STOP OR AT THE VERY LEAST CALL
911-2 SEND AN AMBULANCE.
INSTEAD HE DROVE AWAY ORGANIZED
THE REPAIR OF THE TRACK.
AND RETURNED TO THE SCENE TWO
TIMES THAT DAY WITH HIS FRIENDS
TO ASSESS THE SUIT THE SITUATION.
FROM THE MOMENT THAT THE DRIVER
DECIDED TO DRIVE AWAY HIS
ACTIONS WERE ENTIRELY SELF
SERVING AND COWARDLY.
THANKFULLY A WITNESS WAS JOGGING
NEARBY AND WAS ABLE TO CALL AN
AMBULANCE FOR GAVIN AND PROVIDE
A DESCRIPTION OF THE VEHICLE.
DEVASTATINGLY MY HUSBAND PASSED
AWAY LATER THAT MORNING FROM THE
INJURIES THAT HE SUSTAINED.
THE DRIVER HIT FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR ALMOST A WEEK
WELL MY FAMILY STRUGGLED WITH
THE LOSS OF KEVIN.
AND ALSO WITH THE WEIGHT OF NOT
KNOWING WHAT HAD HAPPENED AND
WHO WAS RESPONSIBLE.
THE DRIVER TURNED HIMSELF IN.
AS THE HIGHWAY TOGETHER AT THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL CLOSE
IN TO ARREST HIM AND IT'S
ULTIMATELY SENTENCE TO JUST
THREE YEARS IN PRISON.
SEPTEMBER SIXTEENTH IN THE WEEKS.
SINCE HAVE BEEN A LIVING
NIGHTMARE FOR MY FAMILY WHO ARE
ALL PRESENT TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO IT'S BEEN SIX
MONTHS SINCE THAT TERRIBLE DAY
AND WE'RE STILL TRYING TO MAKE
SENSE OF THE TRUCK.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE LIGHT
SENDS THAT THE DRIVER RECEIVED
AND THAT'S SIGNAL THAT IT SENDS
TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
THE WAY THAT THE CALIFORNIA LAW
IS WRITTEN SEDATE INCENTIVIZE IS
THE DRIVER TO FLEE THE SCENE
RATHER THAN TO STOP IN THIS IS
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT THEIR
CRITICALLY INJURED WITH THEIR
VEHICLE.
THIS IS WHAT I AND OTHERS HAVE
LEARNED FROM THIS CASE IT WAS IT
HAS BROUGHT AWARENESS TO THE
FACT THAT THERE IS A LOOPHOLE IN
THE CURRENT LEGISLATION.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS
THE INTENT OF THE LAW.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE CORRECTED IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
AND CITIZENS LIKE MYSELF AND ALL
OF YOU.
MYSELF AND OVER TEN THOUSAND
OTHERS ARE ASKING PUT THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT AB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO AND CLOSE THIS
LOOPHOLE.
WITH THE TIME REMAINING --
CHAIRMAN IF IF I'M IF I'M
ALLOWED I WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY HUSBAND.
THIS TO ME.
SO MY HUSBAND GAVIN LIVE LIFE TO
THE FULLEST HE WAS AN
EXCEPTIONAL EDUCATOR AND
ADMINISTRATOR.
HE WAS AN INCREDIBLE SON BROTHER
UNCLE HUSBAND AND FATHER HE WAS
A MAN OF VERY STRONG CHARACTER
WHO DEMONSTRATED PASSION
DEDICATION AUTHENTICITY AND
KINDNESS IN ALL FACETS OF HIS
LIFE.
KEVIN GRADUATED.
FROM UCSB IT WITH AN
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE DEGREE IN
[inaudible]
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND HERE.
VOLUNTEERED WITH THE PEACE CORPS
WHERE HE SPENT TWO YEARS IN THE
GAMBIA IN WEST AFRICA.
HIS LOVE OF TEACHING.
WAS THAT WAS BORN THERE AND
CONTINUED WHEN HE RETURNED TO
THE US AND BEGAN HIS FORMAL
CAREER IN EDUCATION.
HE TAUGHT IN BOTH OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCE ALL EDUCATIONAL
SETTINGS.
AND ALSO IN THE FORMAL
EDUCATIONAL SETTING A CLOSE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HE TAUGHT SCIENCE TO MIDDLE
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
TODD ETIENNE VIRAL SCIENCE TO
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS COACHED
VOLLEYBALL.
COACH MY SON'S SOCCER TEAM.
AND WENT ON TO BECOME VICE
PRESIDENT OR VICE PRINCIPAL AT
FORT WASHINGTON ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN FRESNO.
GAVIN WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
PASSIONATE FUNNY AND GIVING
PERSON.
THE KIND OF PERSON THAT YOU WANT
TO BE AROUND HE HAD FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT WILL CLAIM HAS A
CLAIM HIM AS HIS BEST FRIEND AND
HE WAS LOVED AND RESPECTED BY
THE THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS THAT
HE TAUGHT AMEND TOWARD OVER THE
COURSE OF THIS FOURTEEN YEARS IN
EDUCATION.
HE LOVED THE OUTDOORS AND
SPENDING TIME IN NATURE AND WAS
ALWAYS UP FOR A NEW ADVENTURE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN GROW AND
EXPERIENCE ALL THAT LIFE HAD TO
OFFER.
KEVIN LAWRENCE LEADING DIED ON
SEPTEMBER SIXTEENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUT HIS LEGACY WILL
CONTINUE ON IN THOSE HE LOVED
AND IN THOSE WHO LEFT HIM.
I SINCERELY ASK YOU TO REVISE
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE CODE.
TWO THOUSAND ONE WITH AB.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER GLADYS
. FOR IT CAN
HURT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OF THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR SHIRT ON CAP
KI<c.cyan> HALF OF CRIME VICTIMS</c>
UNITED OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MORNING CHAIRMAN OF ROOM I'M
GOVERNOR RUBY GAVIN WAS MY
BROTHER AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CRITICAL HAVING [inaudible]
CAVS FEATHER.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
GARY GLADDING GAVIN'S FATHER.
THANK YOU SIR.
JACOB GILLIGAN GIVENS FRIEND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
GLENDALE GAVIN'S COUSIN I WORK
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN THIS
BUILDING FOR LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL'S OFFICE DURING WHICH
TIME I HELPED DRAFT THE DSL.
DETERMINATE SENTENCING LAW I
FEEL THIS BILL IS CLEARLY
NECESSARY TO DISTINGUISH.
EGREGIOUS BEHAVIOR THE RESULT IN
KEVIN'S DEATH THANK YOU SIR.
I'M LORENA COIN CABINS AUNT
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS STEVE APPOINT I'M A
RESIDENT OF ALAMEDA COUNTY OF
GAVIN'S UNCLE STEVE.
A RETIRED AS A PEACE OFFICER
AFTER THIRTY YEARS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS AS A PAROLE AGENT
AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
ON CATHERINE JAMESON FROM FRESNO
LONG TIME FRIEND OF THE CLADDING
FAMILY.
TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
JUST WANTED TO ASK YOUR
INDULGENCE FOR THE ONE MINUTE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO HEAR.
ME OF ONE OTHER CASE THAT IS WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE I'M SO
SORRY OF SORRY.
JAMIE JAMISON I AM A LONG TIME
FRIEND OF THE GRANT CLOUDING
FAMILY AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
KATIE ANDERSON FRESNO CALIFORNIA
OF FRIEND OF THE GLIDING
SCHOOLMATE.
OF GAVIN --
AND I'M SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ FROM FRESNO.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
CHRIS PLEDGE FIELD OF LINCOLN
CALIFORNIA KEVIN WAS MY COUSIN I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
PAUL BLANKS FILLED OF SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA AND GAVIN WAS MY
NEPHEW.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
BOB NOYCE REAL SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CABINS UNCLE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR.
DOWN ROSE CLOSE CALIFORNIA LONG
TIME FRIEND OF THE GLIDING
FAMILY COMPLETELY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
ARE THERE ANY.
MORE WITNESSES ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
YES I'M.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN I'M MARGOT
GEORGE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
AND WE OPPOSE AB.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO OF FIRST I WANNA
SAY I'M SO SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS I
CAN'T IMAGINE THE PAIN THAT YOU
WERE FEELING AND I THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S BAD PUBLIC POLICY.
AND LET ME TELL YOU WHY I HAVE
REPRESENTED NUMEROUS PEOPLE WHO
WERE CHARGED WITH HIT AND RUN --
SOME OF THEM WHO WERE CHARGED
WITH HIT AND RUN WITH SERIOUS
INJURIES.
AND THE WAY THE LAW IS DRAFTED
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE AT
FAULT.
IN THE ACCIDENT.
UNDER --
TWENTY THOUSAND AND ONE YOU
MERELY HAVE TO BE INVOLVED SO IF
THE OTHER PARTY.
COULD CAUSES THE ACCIDENT.
AND YOU FULLY YOU'RE STILL.
AND ALL MY CLIENTS --
HAVE FLED FOR MANY REASONS SOME
OF THEM BECAUSE THEY FEARED.
ON BEING DEPORTED SOME BECAUSE
THEY WERE DRIVING ON A SUSPENDED
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
SOME OF THEM BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE INSURANCE.
BUT WHATEVER THE REASON WAS --
THEY HAD NO IDEA WHAT THE LAW
WAS OR WHAT THE SENTENCE WAS.
AND THIS ON A BILL.
OF WOOD WITH NOT BE A DETERRENT
BECAUSE PEOPLE.
IN THOSE SITUATIONS [inaudible]
DON'T KNOW.
ON A FIVE FULLY THAT THIS IS
GOING TO HAPPEN --
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT INCREASING
THE SENATE'S AND THIS BILL SEEKS
TO ALMOST DOUBLE IT.
IN EACH INSTANCE FROM TWO THREE
OR FOUR TO FOUR FIVE OR SIX WITH
INJURY CAUSING DEATH TWO THREE
OR FOUR TO SIX SEVEN OR EIGHT
AND ELIMINATES THE POSSIBILITY
OF A MISDEMEANOR --
WINS -- WITH
THE MINIMUM NINETY DAY JAIL
SENTENCE.
ALL IT DOES IS INCREASE
INCARCERATION AND WE HAVE BEEN
DOWN THAT ROAD BEFORE.
WE HAVE TAKEN SCARCE PUBLIC
RESOURCES TO BUILD MORE AND MORE
PRISONS.
AND IT HAS NOT BEEN A SUCCESS.
FOR THOSE REASONS I ASKS FOR
YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA AND LET ME ALSO
SAY THAT I OFFER MY SYMPATHY TO
THE THE FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND
I'M SO SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS --
I THINK ALL OF US IN IN RESPONSE
TO A TRAGEDY LIKE THIS WANT TO
FIND WAYS TO KEEP IT FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE --
UNFORTUNATELY INCREASING THE
SENTENCES FOR FOR FLEEING THE
SCENE ARE ARE NOT GOING TO DO
THAT THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
PREVENT FUTURE DEATHS OR
INJURIES FROM CAR ACCIDENTS.
OR EVEN TO TURN DRIVERS FROM
FLEEING THE SCENE AFTER AN
ACCIDENT --
INSTEAD IT TIES JUDGES HANDS SO
THAT THEY ARE FORCED TO IMPOSE
PRISON SENTENCES IN.
THE CASES WHERE THOSE SENTENCES
MAYBE LEAST APPROACH MORE PEOPLE
TO PRISON FOR LONGER PERIODS OF
TIME -- AND
UNFORTUNATELY WITH LITTLE OR NO
BENEFIT TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NOVA.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CNN ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM --
SO FIRST OF ALL.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AND WE HAVE MOST OF OUR MEMBERS
HERE RIGHT NOW.
THAT WE ATTEND THESE HEARINGS
AND TO HEAR ARGUMENTS ON BOTH
SIDES.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WHEN YOU
MENTION THE LOOPHOLE I WANTED TO
CHECK ON THIS AND I'VE CHECKED
WITH STAFF AND IT IS TRUE.
THAT IF YOU WERE DRUNK AND YOU
HIT SOMEONE.
AND YOU STAY YOU CAN GET FOUR
YEARS OR MORE.
WORDS IF YOU LEAVE AND THEN
YOU'RE NOT TESTED.
AND YOU COME BACK AT YEAH THEY
FIND YOU A DAY LATER THEY THEY
CERTAINLY WHAT THEY'RE PROBABLY
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO CONVICT YOU
FOR DRUNK DRIVING FAIR FOR YOU
TO GET LESS THE SENTENCE.
BECAUSE I FOUND THIS OUT RIGHT
NOW AT THE HEARING.
I'M.
I'M NOT PREPARED TO VOTE YES I'M
NOT PREPARED TO VOTE NO.
I THINK WE NEED SOME TIME ON
THIS.
OF FOR YOU IN THE CHAIR TO
CONFER.
OF THE ALTERNATIVES FRANKLY I I
WOULDN'T GO FORWARD WITH THE
BILL RIGHT NOW I'D BE AND NOT
VOTING AND THAT'S THE SAME AS OF
NOW.
BUT WHAT I'D LIKE IS FOR YOU IN
THE CHAIR TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND
THEN PERHAPS WE CAN BRING IT
BACK.
AND DECIDE ON THE RIGHT THING TO
DO BUT JUST FINDING THIS OUT AT
THE LAST MINUTE I AM.
I'M REALLY NOT IN A POSITION TO
MAKE A DECISION RIGHT NOW.
MISS POWER CARE.
THANK YOU MRS LEADING FOR COMING.
FROM AS A MOTHER.
OF YOUNG KIDS AS WELL I CAN'T
IMAGINE THE PAIN THAT YOU'VE
BEEN THROUGH IN THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS AND I SO APPRECIATE YOU
COMING AND SHARING YOUR HUSBAND
STORY.
THANK YOU --
SO I BELIEVE I THINK BOTH OF YOU
HAVE IMPORTANT POINTS TO RAISE
THEIR AGREE JUST CIRCUMSTANCES
LIKE THE ONES DESCRIBED HERE
WERE EIGHT YEARS IS ABSOLUTELY
PERHAPS WITH THE JUDGE IN THIS
SEARCH ATTORNEY WOULD FIND
APPROPRIATE AND WE SHOULD.
CONSIDER RAISING THE PENALTY IN
THAT CASE I ALSO HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING.
NOT EVERY CASE IN THE CRIMINAL
SYSTEM IS THE SAME RIGHT AND
THEY'RE SITUATIONS THAT ARE LESS
EGREGIOUS THAN THE ONE PRESENTED
HERE TODAY.
AND IN THOSECASES MAYBE TWO
YEARS IS APPROPRIATE.
SO I AM.
IN A PLACE WHERE I SEE THE MAYBE
THERE IS AN IN BETWEEN WHICH IS
TO KEEP THE FLOOR IT TWO YEARS
BUT TO RAISE IT TO EIGHT YEARS
AS A TOP PENALTY AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING YOU'D
BE OPEN TO MR PATERSON BUT I'M --
YOU KNOW I'M SORT OF WITH MISTER
QUIRK RIGHT NOW WHERE THAT
SOMETHING I WOULD ACTUALLY
CONSIDER BECAUSE I THINK THERE
ARE CASES.
LIKE MRS GLIDING'S WHERE EIGHT
YEARS.
IS RIGHT BUT I ALSO DON'T WANT
TO TAKE THE DISCRETION AWAY FROM
THOSE IN THE SYSTEM TO USED
HERE'S WHERE THE CASE IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE ONE DESCRIBED
SO.
I PUT THAT TO YOU [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
SO I AM.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR COMING
AND SHARING YOUR STORY AND FOR
BRINGING --
HIS RELATIVES AND HIS FRIENDS
AND PEOPLE WHO LOVE THEM. TO
KEEP HIS MEMORY AND KEEP HIS
LIFE ALIVE I AM [inaudible]
IT IS.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE --
AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
THAT PERSON WHO KILLED YOUR
HUSBAND HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
DECENCY.
AND TO RUN AND THEN TRIED TO
COVER IT UP.
WHATEVER COURAGE HE MAY HAVE HAD.
WAS DEPLETED.
IN THAT INSTANCE.
AND LIKE MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES I
TO HAVE SOME CONCERNS I HAVE
CONCERNS WITH WHEN WE TRY TO
ENHANCE PUNISHMENTS [inaudible]
NOT.
UNDERSTANDING THAT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES TO OTHER KINDS OF
FOLKS HAPPEN IN THE PENDULUM
BEGINS TO SWING OTHER WAYS IN
WAYS THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT OTHER FOLKS.
WHO WHO HAVE DIFFERENT STORIES
LIKE SOME OF THE STORIES THAT
WERE SHARED --
BY -- THE
WOMEN HERE I I THINK THAT --
JUDGES DO HAVE DISCRETION.
AND THEY HAVE MULTIPLE TOOLS AT
THEIR DISPOSAL WITH THE LAW TO
STACK SENTENCES ON TOP OF ONE
ANOTHER TO TRY TO GET THE KIND
OF PUNISHMENT.
FOLKS FEEL --
IS WORTHY --
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE COMMITTED
THOSE KINDS OF CRIMES AND I
THINK HIT AND RUNS ARE.
ALSO VERY CHALLENGING BECAUSE
THEY ARE.
LEFT OPEN TO INTERPRETATION BY
BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND BY
PROSECUTORS.
SOME WILL INTERPRET GOING THREE
BLOCKS VERY DIFFERENTLY FROM
GOING FIVE MILES VERY
DIFFERENTLY FROM GOING HOME AND
TRYING TO YOU KNOW FIX UP A
BANGED UP CAR.
AND SO HOW WE RECTIFY SOME OF
THOSE NUANCES --
THAT CAN ONCE AGAIN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
CERTAIN FOLKS WHO HAVE ALREADY
BEEN HIT BY THE SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE HAVE PUT
FORTH OVER THE COURSE OF THE
YEARS.
IS SOMETHING THAT AS A MEMBER OF
THIS POLICY BODY I AM VERY
INTERESTED IN TRYING TO CORRECT
WITH A MUCH MORE LASER FOCUS
THEN BROUGHT ENHANCEMENTS SO I
AM IN AGREEMENT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT I WOULD BE OPEN
TO SOME KIND OF AMENDMENTS BEING
BROUGHT FORTH AN ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS. TO BE HAD AROUND
THIS BILL BEFORE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ACCOMMODATE
OF MR LACKEY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I GUESS I'M A BIT CONFUSED BY
THE BY THE NUANCE THAT SEEMS TO
BE CREATED HERE THIS IS VERY
CLEAR CUT.
THIS IS A HUGE INJUSTICE.
AND ME JUST TELL YOU THAT --
I HAVE PERSONALLY.
NOT ONLY WITNESS BUT BEEN
INVOLVED WITH.
INTERACTIONS WITH OTHER FAMILIES
THAT HAVE DEALT WITH THIS TYPE
OF TRAGEDY [inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW THE THE DEFENSE
TALKED ABOUT [inaudible]
LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
AND THAT IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF LEGISLATION.
AND I WOULD CHALLENGE THIS
COMMITTEE AND EVERYBODY ASSIGNED
TO THIS COMMITTEE. TO THINK
ABOUT LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
AND ARE WE HERE. TO ALLOW FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY TO BE CARRIED OUT.
OR WE HEAR TO ALWAYS SYMPATHIZED
WITH THE FENDERS.
IT GETS VERY VERY TIRESOME.
AND I'D I DON'T SAY THAT IT'S
NOT NORMAL TO BE SYMPATHETIC.
BUT WHEN YOU.
HAVE SOMEBODY THE EXPERIENCE THE
TRAGEDY ASSOCIATED WITH DEATH
NEEDLESS DEATH.
CHANGES THE PICTURE.
I WOULD HOPE.
CERTAINLY DID FOR THE VICTIM
[inaudible]
IN ARGUABLE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WHEN WE START
TALKING ABOUT THESE VERY
DELICATE ISSUES.
VICTIMS ARE REALLY REALLY ARE
FORGOTTEN.
WITH WE TALK ABOUT VICTIMS'
FAMILIES BECAUSE WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THEM.
WHAT TO LOOK AT THE VICTIM
THEY'RE GONNA [inaudible]
THAT'S SHAMEFUL.
THAT SHAMEFUL THE WE DISCOUNT.
THE TRAGEDIES ASSOCIATED WITH
LOSS OF LIFE.
IN THIS I AM SO SORRY.
THIS HAPPEN TO YOUR FAMILY.
BUT WE COULD DO A LITTLE BIT OF
SOMETHING THAT MEANS A GREAT
DEAL.
AND THAT IS.
ADDRESS FUTURE CIRCUMSTANCES
WITH THIS AND JUSTICE WE WE
CAN'T BE PROMOTING --
ENCOURAGING.
PEOPLE TO LEAVE THE SCENE.
WHAT'S SOMETHING SO HORRIBLE HAS
JUST OCCURRED.
BUT WE'RE AND I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY IN THEIR LEGISLATIVE
INTENT DESIRED THAT.
WHAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND I I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE.
PEOPLE PUT A LOT OF TRUST IN US
ON THIS COMMITTEE. TO ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATION THAT MAKES
OUR PUBLIC MORE SAFETY.
SAFE THAT'S WHY WE'RE CALLED
PUBLIC SAFETY.
ONLY PASSED LEGISLATION THAT
MAKES THEM LESS SAFE.
WE'RE BETRAYING THAT TRUST.
SO I WOULD HOPE IN THIS VERY
VERY SENSITIVE VERY VERY
DELICATE.
ISSUE THAT WE WILL SHOW.
THE WE'RE NOT GOING TO BETRAY
THAT TRUST.
AND WE ARE GOING TO ADDRESS THIS
AND JUSTICE.
IN A MEANINGFUL WAY AND YOU
PROVIDE AS A WAY TO DO THAT SO
I'VE FULLY IN SUPPORT AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING THE COURAGE TO
BRING THIS FORWARD [inaudible]
THE AND THE MISS WORK OF THANK
YOU WAS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
SHERMAN FIRSTLY I WANT TO THINK
OF MY MY COLLEAGUE DR COURT FOR
A OF ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THERE IS
A LOOPHOLE IN OUR CURRENT PENAL
CODE THAT.
REALLY.
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE --
TO TO TO AVOID A OF BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE --
AND AND I WANT TO THINK OF SOME
WOMEN ARE PATTERSON FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL --
FOR HI I THINK I WOULD JOIN --
MY VICE CHAIR IN A SUPPORTING
THIS BILL --
SO THAT WE CAN.
BRING BACK ON SOME SENSE OF
JUSTICE OF FOR THOSE THAT WERE --
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY THIS CRIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
THANK YOU AND MISS WORK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
ANOTHER FOR TWO YEAR OLD.
AND MY HUSBAND MY FAMILY ARE
EVERYTHING TO ME SO I COULD ONLY
BENCH.
AND I WON ALIGN MYSELF WITH MR
QUIRK AND MISS BARRICADE HENIN'S
COOPERATIVES COMMENTS.
IN THAT -- I
WOULD REQUEST THAT WE HAVE MORE
TIME TO THINK SOME OF THE STUFF
THROUGH.
BECAUSE WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- THE
PUNISHMENT MEETS THE CRIME BUT
WE ALSO WANNA BE MINDFUL OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
SOME OF THIS LEGISLATION CAN
HAVE AND I AM --
SOMEONE WHO IS --
CONCERNED ABOUT BLINK AT
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THE SENATE AND
CONSEQUENCES BUT I'M ALSO VERY
SYMPATHETIC.
TO SO I JUST WANNA LET MYSELF
WITH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ON MISTER PATTERSON YOU MAY
CLOSE.
I'M A MEMBERS I AM MISTER CHAIR
PRECIADO.
VERY VERY MUCH THE CONVERSATION
THAT HAS.
TAKEN PLACE HERE.
WE WE HAVE ESTABLISHED SOMETHING
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ON
THERE IS A LOOPHOLE HERE.
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THOSE WHO.
SUGGESTED UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN ONE PARTICULAR
DIRECTION.
THERE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
IN THE OTHER DIRECTION AS WELL.
AND THOSE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES MEAN THAT.
IN A PERVERSE WAY.
SOMEONE WHO PURPOSEFULLY FLEAS
HIT AND RUN.
FACES LESS PENALTY THAT IF THEY
STAYED.
AND WE CAN CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE.
I UNDERSTAND THIS COMMITTEES.
CONCERN OVER --
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS BILL DOES.
FLY IN THE FACE A BIT OF THE THE
THE PLACE WHERE I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE.
AS A MAJORITY.
MOVES.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THERE COMES
SOME MOMENT.
WHEN THE FAX IN FRONT OF US AND
THE APPARENT [inaudible]
AN OBVIOUS.
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS UNINTENDED
[inaudible]
CONSEQUENCE.
REALLY REQUIRES US. TO TRY TO
WORK THROUGH THIS [inaudible]
AND I SO I I I APPRECIATE THE
SENTIMENT.
MISTER CHAIR I I AM GLAD TO WORK
ON THIS.
BUT I AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
SIR I HAVE BEEN HERE BEFORE.
AND IT HAS BEEN SUGGESTED TO ME
THAT.
I WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE.
ON OTHER BILLS.
THAT NEVER TOOK PLACE.
IS THERE A SERIOUS.
COMMITMENT FROM THE CHAIR AND
FROM THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT WE WILL WORK ON CLOSING
THIS LOOPHOLE.
AND CAN WE WORK TOGETHER TO GET
TO A YES.
INSTEAD OF A NO.
I AM WILLING TO DO EVERYTHING IN
MY POWER. TO WORK THROUGH THAT.
I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH OTHERS
WHO HAVE BEEN.
PARTICIPATING IN FINDING THE
LOOPHOLE UNDERSTANDING IT AND
TRYING [inaudible]
TO CLOSE IT --
SO I'M.
IN A BIT OF A QUANDARY TO KNOW
HOW WE PROCEED.
THERE'S A PART OF ME THAT SAYS I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THIS COMMITTEE
TO VOTE IN FAVOR.
AND IF THERE'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND THEN LET'S TAKE A VOTE --
FAILING THAT I AM OPEN TO WHAT
EVER KIND OF LEGITIMATE.
TIMELY.
EFFORT TO WORK THROUGH TO GET
THE LOOPHOLE CLOSED.
AND I WOULD ASK THAT THERE BE.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE CHAIR
CAN INSTRUCT THE STAFF.
BUT I WOULD ASK THAT.
WE TRIED TO FIND A WAY TO SAY
YES.
INSTEAD OF SIMPLY DELAYING.
UNTIL IT NO LONGER IS ELIGIBLE
TO BE HEARD.
I WOULD LIKE TO TRUST.
BUT I NEED TO VERIFY.
THANK YOU WITH ADAM I JUST
WONDER MY JUST IN THE CLOSE.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE?
IS TO CHANGE.
THE PRESIDENT HIT AND RUN
[inaudible]
CULTURE [inaudible]
AND IF WE HAD THIS LAW ON THE
BOOKS AND IF WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE.
THE INFORMATION THROUGH THE
MEDIA AND OTHERS THAT IF YOU HIT
RUN LEAVE.
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY AS MUCH A
PENALTY FORCE OR MORE THAN IF
YOU STAY IN BE A HUMAN BEING.
THIS IS A I THINK A VERY LOUD
AND CLEAR DETERRENT.
THAT IF THEY HIT HER KILL AND
LEAVE.
THAT THEY WILL FACE A PENALTY.
THE OPPOSITION SUGGESTS THAT
THIS IS AN ENHANCEMENT.
WE ARGUE THAT THIS IS NOTHING
MORE THAN PUTTING PARITY IN.
TO THIS LAW SO THAT LEAVING THE
SCENE IS TREATED MUCH LIKE
VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER.
THE TICKET A MANSLAUGHTER
CARRIES THE SIMILAR KINDS OF OF
PENALTIES.
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER VOTING IN
FAVOR OF THIS.
IF IT SHOULD PASS THROUGH YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT.
THAT WE WILL IN FACT WORK ON
OTHER.
A AMENDMENTS ARE OTHER WAYS.
TO SETTLE OUT SOME OF THE
CONCERN THAT TO YOU AND STAFF
MIGHT HAVE.
BUT LET'S FIRST START FROM A
COMMITTEE COMMITMENT. TO GET TO
A YES.
INSTEAD OF A NO.
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON AND YOU AND I HAVE --
OBVIOUSLY HAD DIFFERENCES ON
VARIOUS BILLS --
OBVIOUSLY SOUNDS LIKE WE NEED TO
IMPROVE.
HOW WE WORK TOGETHER AND I I
WILL ASSURE YOU?
ON THIS BILL ESPECIALLY.
WE WILL TRY TO WORK THROUGH SOME
SOLUTION PROPOSITION AND MAYBE
NEITHER SIDE LIKES BUT WILL COME
TO SOLUTION.
BUT BEFORE THAT I WHAT I WANTED
TO TO MAKE SURE I SAID I'VE BEEN
ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR SEVEN
YEARS -- AND
MRS SUSAN CLADDING.
YOU ARE THE FIRST WITNESS.
THAT EVER COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE.
THAT BASICALLY TURNED TO
COMMITTEE THROUGH YOUR
COMPASSIONATE EMOTIONAL
TESTIMONY --
EVEN.
THE CONSULTANT FOR PORAC.
YOU BROUGHT HIM TO TEARS --
AND DOES NOT AN EASY TASK IF YOU
KNOW RANDY --
YOU'VE GOTTEN SOME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
AND IT TEARS.
SO I'M LETTING YOU KNOW YOU.
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE IN THE
SEVEN YEARS YOU'VE BEEN THE MOST
POWERFUL.
ADVOCATE FOR YOUR COST SPEAKER
THAT WE'VE EVER HAD.
AND I WILL TELL YOU YOU WERE
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
BECAUSE I'M PRETTY CERTAIN
MISTER PATTERSON.
WE WERE AT NO. TWO UNDECIDED FOR
THE MAJORITY OF FOLKS HERE.
AND WHAT I'M GOING TO PROPOSE AS
A SOLUTION.
SO THAT JUAN MEMBERS HOPEFULLY.
THE LINE'S SPECIAL ONES LIKE
MYSELF THERE WERE IT NO --
THAT WE GET TO A NO VOTE.
AND WE GIVE YOU RECONSIDERATION.
WANT TO GIVE YOU MORE TIME
[inaudible] TO YOU NEED TO KNOW
THAT MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
EVEN LOWERED EXXON LIKE WERE
TALKING THROUGH SOME OF YOUR
SPEECH AND I HAD A QUIET THEM
DOWN.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET TO A
SOLUTION HERE RIGHT NOW.
ON THE COMMITTEE.
AND WE JUST NEED MORE TIME.
YOU HAVE MEMBERS HERE.
REGARDLESS OF THE YOU'RE NOT OUR
RELATIONSHIP OR HOW WE WORK TWO
THINGS THEIR MEMBERS NOW ON THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WANT TO WORK
THROUGH A SOLUTION.
WHICH IS MORE POWERFUL THAN MY
ONE VOTE.
AND AND THEY'RE THOROUGHLY
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT STAFF.
WORK THROUGH A SOLUTION MISSION
YOU HAVE MEMBERS THAT.
I WILL SAY NOW BELIEVE YOUR
MEMBERS THAT THE POINT YOU MADE
ABOUT THIS BEING A LOOPHOLE.
THEY GET IT.
ANYONE A CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE ON
TO DRUNK DRIVING [inaudible]
FELONY --
ISSUE WHILE MAKING SURE. FOR ME.
SOMEONE HAS A PREDOMINATE LATINO
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
THAT MOSTLY HAS MAYBE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THEY GET STOPPED IN MY
DISTRICT ARE LATINO.
WHO MAY NOT BE FULL CITIZENS WHO
AFRAID AND TAKE OFF [inaudible]
OR PEOPLE FORMING INCARCERATED.
THAT TAKE OFF BECAUSE THEY'VE
HAD BAD RUN INS.
BUT THEY'RE NOT DRUNK.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO GET THEM.
ENTRAPPED ARE ENGINEERED.
INTO SOMETHING THAT I I BELIEVE.
AND I'M THAT THERE IS A SWEET
SPOT SOMEWHERE.
AND AND THAT.
YOU CAN TAKE BACK TO NOT ONLY
MRS GLIDING'S BALL HER FAMILY
MEMBERS AND IS SPECIAL AND THE
ONES THAT I CUT OFF.
I I WOULDN'T CUTTING OFF TO BE
MEANS JUST WE HAD LIMITED TIME.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT.
YOU HAD BEST SPEAKER RIGHT HERE.
SPEAKING ON YOUR BEHALF SHE WAS
GREAT.
AND AFTER SHE SPOKE --
WE DIDN'T NEED ANYMORE.
AND SELL OUT.
I I WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
IF WE WOULD NOT VOTE AND THAT WE
WOULD GIVE YOU RECONSIDERATION.
SO THAT WE CAN THEN NOT ONLY
TALK ABOUT.
TIME FOR US TO COME TO DIRECTORS
UP TO WHEN HE COMES BACK WITH
HIS BOOK TO VOTE ONLY WITH.
HOPEFULLY THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT EVERYBODY FEELS COMFORTABLE
WITH I'D ANY DENTIST AND THE THE
PROCESS HERE TO DO SO WE WE HAVE
A IF IT DIES IN COMMITTEE DID
YOU ASK TO RECONSIDER IT AND
THEN THAT OPENS THE PROCESS FOR
US TO YES HAVE THESE KINDS OF
CONVERSATIONS.
M. I HAVE COMMITMENTS FROM.
ALL THE MEMBERS HERE AND THE
CHAIR TO GET THIS.
TO WE'RE ALL GONNA WORK A CLOSER
ACT AND LET'S NOT. TO ANOTHER TO
ANOTHER LEVEL TRANSPARENCY.
SO THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
WHATEVER WILK SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
COME UP EVERYBODY KNOWS ALL THE
DIFFERENT.
PERMUTATIONS THAT COME OUT TO
THESE NEGOTIATIONS AND HAVING
ALL SIDES IN TO TALK ABOUT IT.
SO IT'S NOT JUST ME AND YOU TALK
ABOUT OUR STAFF AND STAFF
TALKING WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT A
BETTER METHODOLOGY THAT WE
INCLUDE EVERY MEMBER HERE SO YOU
CAN'T DO THAT.
IF WE ARE JOINTLY WORKING ON THE
LOOPHOLE YES WE WE DO HAVE AN
AGREEMENT HERE WE HAVE A
CONSENSUS THAT THERE IS IN FACT
A PROBLEMATIC LOOPHOLE.
IT DOES EXIST AND IT PERVERSE
LEE OF REWARD.
I'M SO I APPRECIATED --
IF YOU CALL THE QUESTION AND AND
IT FAILED FAILS --
TO FAILED TO PASS I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION WHICH
WILL BEGIN A PROCESS THAT YOU
YOU IT WILL BE.
AND I KNOW I HAVE TO MAKE.
AND I KNOW THAT.
THANK YOU SIR IT THAT'LL CLOSE.
SO I PROBABLY NEED MY ROOF.
PUBLIC IN COLLEAGUES TO SAY
SOMETHING FIRST.
COURSE OF THE MOVIE BILL --
YEAH.
SECOND THE MOTION.
ON EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY TO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
GEN SO YOU'RE NOT VOTING LACKEY
LACKEY AYE BARRA CAN.
BARRICADE CANNOT VOTING DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF NOT VOTING
QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING SANTIAGO WICKS.
WICKS NOT VOTING.
AT MEASURE FAILS BUT IT DIDN'T
FAIL.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY YOUR RECONSIDERATION
L. THANK AND MEMBERS AND YOU'RE
ASKING FOR RE A RECONSIDERATION
ABSOLUTELY.
AND IF THERE'S NO OF NO
PROJECTION UNANIMOUS ABOUT.
THAT I DO WANT YOU TO KNOW WE
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE HERE WHO
DID NOT VOTE FOR THIS.
BUT I KNOW WHERE YOUR HEARTS ARE
YOU DEMONSTRATED THAT TODAY I'M
VERY GRATEFUL AND I KNOW THE
FAMILY IS.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
A SIGNATURE SHOE.
I WANTED TO CHECK.
IS THE VEHICLE MORE [inaudible]
SHOP [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ALTHOUGH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
BOB.
I'M READY.
TO RUN.
WHAT THE BOTH HERE?
IT IT IT.
MR CHOW I MISSED IT YOU ARE HERE
[inaudible] ONE AB THREE
HUNDRED ITEM NUMBER.
ONE DESTRUCTIVE --
MUCH -- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR TEN MEMBERS.
AB THREE HUNDRED ENSURED THAT
HATE CRIMES AND HATE INCIDENCES
IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE ACCURATELY IDENTIFY REPORT
AND INVESTIGATED.
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT THE
CRYING AND INCIDENT REPORT USED
BY THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
INCLUDE A CHECK BOX INDICATING
WEATHERED THE CASE AT HAND IN A
HATE CRIME OR HATE INCIDENT.
IT ALSO REQUIRED THAT FOR EACH
THE AGENCY MUST COMPLETE A
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT SUBSCRIBE TO
FIND THAT TYPE OF BIAS
MOTIVATION INVOLVED.
AND OTHER IMPORTANT RELEVANT IN.
IN THE PROSECUTION OF THE CASE.
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL WAS --
RE ITERATED FROM THE ISSUE THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HEY CRIME REPORT FONG
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR.
WHICH I WORK WITH OTHER MEMBERS
AND CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS TO
REQUEST.
IN THE REPORT AN AUDIT ALL FOUR
MAJOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
SHOWED THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOUSE NOT ADEQUATELY IDENTIFY
REPORTER.
OR RESPONDED TO HATE CRIME.
THE REPORT SUGGESTS START LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY UPDATE THEIR
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES ON HATE
CRYING AND IMPLEMENT.
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING.
GOOD THE TIME TO DO DOES IS NOW
BIG BECAUSE HATE CRIMES ARE ON
THE RIGHTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE FORCE YEARS IN THE ROLE.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
STUDY.
OF HATE AND X. TRIM IS AN APP
CALLED THE FINAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SAN BERNARDINO.
ACROSS ACCORDING TO THE STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HEY CRYING.
YOU BàN TO INCREASE SEVENTEEN
POINT 4% FROM.
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO SEVENTEEN
THEREFORE ENSURING THAT HATE
CRIMES AND HATE INCIDENCES ARE
ACCURATELY IDENTIFIED REPORTED.
AND INVESTIGATE IT IS VITAL FORD
IS NANCY A BILL.
FROM THE ANTI DEFAMATION THAT
THAT FILMATION'S LEAGUE.
AND GREAT.
DAY G. D. JEERS THANK YOU FROM
THE ARC CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING I'M SORRY I HAVE MY
BACK TO SOME OF YOU HOWEVER.
MY NAME'S NANCY OF PELHAM
CALIFORNIA OF LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE.
WE SUBMITTED A SUPPORT LETTER
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
CHOOSE BILL AB THREE HUNDRED AND
WE HAVE DEEP AND BROAD
EXPERIENCE WITH HATE CRIME.
AND IT'S DETAILED IN THAT LETTER
SO I WON'T TAKE UP YOUR TIME NOW.
CALIFORNIA AS WE KNOW HAS A
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF HATE CRIME
LAWS THAT TO MODEL FOR EVERY
OTHER STATE IN THE NATION.
BUT LAWS ARE ONLY AS EFFECTIVE
AS THEIR IMPLEMENTATION.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST SAID
WE KNOW THROUGH NUMEROUS INDICIA
THAT HATE CRIMES ARE NOTORIOUSLY
UNDER REPORTED BOTH IN THE FIRST
INSTANCE BY VICTIMS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEN BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
YET EVEN THE DATA WE DO HAVE
SHOW THAT HATE CRIME IS A
GROWING PROBLEM IN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN OF COURSE WE SAW A AYE
POPPING SEVENTEEN POINT 4%
INCREASE IN JUST AND REPORTED
HATE CRIME.
AND OF COURSE --
THE THE CS YOU ARE SAN BERNADINO
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF HATE AND
EXTREMISM ALSO PREDICTS ANOTHER
RISE.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NEVERTHELESS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT ENTITLED
HATE CRIMES IN CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS NOT ADEQUATELY
IDENTIFIED REPORTED OR RESPONDED
TO HATE CRIMES.
BY ITS TITLE SUMS UP WELL HOW WE
NEED TO DO MORE TO MAKE OUR HATE
CRIME LAWS AS EFFECTIVE AS
POSSIBLE.
IN RELEVANT PART.
THE AUDITOR RECOMMENDS THAT LAW
ENFORCED SACRAMENTO REPORTS FOR
REPORTED HATE CRIMES.
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTS PLUS THE
ADDITION OF THE CHECK BOX ON
INITIAL REPORTS FOR SUSPECTED
HATE CRIMES AND HATE INCIDENTS
AS DEFINED WILL HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS KEEP THE
POSSIBILITY THAT.
THE OF THAT AND EVENTS MAY BE
BIASED MOTIVATED WHILE THEY'RE
RESPONDING INITIALLY AND THEN
FOLLOW UP.
THIS WILL INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY WILL
INVESTIGATE POSSIBLE HATE CRIMES
AS THOROUGHLY AND EFFECTIVELY AS
AS POSSIBLE FROM THE GET GO.
THE INCLUSION OF A SUSPECTED
HATE IS INCIDENT IS ALSO
SIGNIFICANT.
THESE HATE INCIDENTS PROVIDE
VALUABLE INFORMATION AND
INTELLIGENCE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
IMPACTING THE SAFETY OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES. EIGHT INCIDENT
IDENTIFYING HATE INCIDENTS AND
TRACKING THEM CAN ALSO AID IN
CRIME PREVENTION AS HATE
INCIDENTS ARE FREQUENTLY THE
PRECURSORS TO MORE SERIOUS HATE
CRIMES.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY I
HATE CRIMES ARE UNDER REPORTED.
BUT LIKELY HIGH AMONG THEM IS A
LACK OF SUFFICIENT AWARENESS OF
THE POSSIBILITY THAT ONE HAS
EVEN OCCURRED.
BY ADDING THE CHECK BOX IN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL BE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO INVESTIGATE THE
POSSIBILITY WHEN THERE IS
EVIDENCE POINTING TO IT.
THANK YOU.
GREG HERE WITH THE ARK IN UNITED
TO RECALL THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION A COALITION OF
PEOPLE WITH.
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES --
FRIENDS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS
WITH THIRTY SIX CHAPTERS AND
AFFILIATES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA --
A HATE CRIME.
AS A MATTER AS A IN A PRACTICAL
MATTER DOESN'T EXIST UNTIL THE
INITIAL RESPONDING PERFECT BY
THE OFFICER SAYS IT DOES --
IF.
THE OFFICER DOES NOT COLLECT THE
THE EVIDENCE THERE IS NO CHANCE
THAT THE HIGH RANKING PEOPLE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OR THE DA WILL
EVER PROSECUTED IS ALSO WILL
NEVER.
SHOW UP IN ANY OF THE STATISTICS.
THIS IS NOT JUST A MATTER OF
STATISTICS.
IT'S A MATTER OF JUSTICE FOR THE
VICTIMS OF THE OF THESE CRIMES.
OUT WHILE ALL HE CRIMES UNDER
REPORTED AND CONFIRM THAT WHAT
WE'VE ALSO SEEN CALIFORNIA.
ANTI DISABILITY HATE CRIMES ARE
A PARTICULARLY AND REPORTED.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
NATIONAL CRIME VICTIMIZATION
SURVEY ESTIMATED THAT FROM
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN THERE ARE AN
AVERAGE OF FORTY THOUSAND AND I
DISABILITY HATE CRIMES PER YEAR
IN THE UNITED STATES. FORTY
THOUSAND THIS WAS UNDOUBTEDLY AN
UNDERESTIMATE BECAUSE THE SURVEY
DID NOT COVER PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND HOSPITALS GROUP
HOMES AND OTHER STUDENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
THIRD YEAR OF A OF A SURGE --
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY REPORTED
JUST ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN AND
I DISABILITY HATE CRIMES THE FBI.
LESS THAN 3% OF THE DOJ SERVICE
ABOUT. FORTY FORTY THOUSAND
ESTIMATED HUNDRED SIXTEEN
REPORTED.
THE IN CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT MOST RECENT YEAR
WE HAVE STATISTICS.
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT REPORTED
JUST. FOR FOUR AND I DISABILITY
A CRIMES.
THE BILL HAS TWO PARTS WHAT IS
THE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT FORM
WHICH IS THE THE ONLY WAY.
THAT -- THAT
HIGH RANKING OFFICERS
INVESTIGATORS AND DA'S WILL EVER
KNOW THAT THERE'S A HATE CRIME
TO BE AS TO MENTION WAS
RECOMMENDED BY THE AUDIT.
THE OTHERS THE CHECK BOX WHICH
WE KNOW WHAT WORKS WHEN THE LAPD
ADDED THE CHECK BOX TO THEIR
FORMS --
SOME YEARS AGO THE IT'S WHEN UP.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION
[inaudible]
HELLO.
HELLO MY NAME IS UNION OCCURS
YES AND I'M WITH THE COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS
CALIFORNIA THE NATION'S LARGEST
AWESOME SO RIGHT GROUP.
IN STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
Q..
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA SERVING
THE STATE'S DIVERSE LGBT Q.
POPULAR POPULATION.
AND THEN PROUD SUPPORT OF AB
THREE HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK.
CHRISTINA GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
THREE HUNDRED THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING.
COURSE ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION --
HERE RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL IT IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT.
THIS BILL AS A MECHANISM SOLVES
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MAY BE
UNDER REPORTING OF HATE CRIME --
ALLEGE BUT IT'S UNCLEAR HOW THIS
AS A MECHANISM ADDRESSES THAT
ARE FIXES IT EXISTING LAW
ALREADY REQUIRES REPORTING OF
HATE CRIMES.
THAT REPORTING INCLUDES THE
NATURE OF THE BIAS INHERENT IN
THE CRIME AS WELL AS VICTIM
CHARACTERISTICS FENCE TYPE THE
LOCATION OF THE OFFENSE THAT
SORT OF INFORMATION.
HAVING A CHECK BOX TO THE COVER
REPORT --
AND REQUIRING --
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING IT'S JUST
LIKE IT IS IN NATURE IT'S EITHER
GOING TO BE IN THE REPORTER IT'S
NOT.
IF IT IS THEN IT'LL BE AN
COVERED AND IF IT'S NOT THEN WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S
POTENTIALLY A PROBLEM WITH A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT.
REASONS THAT WOULDN'T BE IN THE
REPORT IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW THIS
IS THE SOLUTION TO THAT PROBLEM --
THE WITNESSES SPOKE OF A
INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WELL HOW DO
WE KNOW THAT IF THIS THESE DATA
ARE BEING REPORTED.
THE DATA ARE BEING REPORTED IT'S
UNCLEAR WHAT BENEFIT ADDING THE
CHECK BOX IN THE SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTS WILL ADD --
IF IT'S IN THE REPORT IT'LL BE
THERE IF IT'S NOT IT WON'T HELP
WITH THAT AND IF NOT IF THERE'S
A PROBLEM WITH ASCERTAINING
INFORMATION FROM THE REPORT.
AND THAT'S A DIFFERENT MATTER
BUT ADDING THIS DUPLICATIVE
REQUIREMENT.
TO IF YOU'VE ALREADY WRITTEN
SOMETHING IN YOUR REPORT THAT
HAS TO DO WITH THE UP A
PERCEIVED BIAS IN WHAT HAPPENED.
THEN YOU'LL BE DUPLICATING THAT
A SECOND REPORT AND CHECKING THE
BOX SO AGAIN IT WE JUST DON'T
SEE WHAT THIS REALLY SOLVES IT'S
DUPLICATIVE IT'S GONNA TAKE
RESOURCES.
AWAY FROM OTHER THINGS AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE POSTED CLICK
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MISS COLORADO.
THANK YOU SO I AM --
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO RESTATE
THAT IT IS REALLY ABOUT
REPORTING WE KNOW THAT HATE
CRIMES JUST LIKE DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
ARE ON THE RISE AND YET
UNFORTUNATELY.
IT IS INCREDIBLY HARD.
THAT THERE'S MOTIVATION AND
INTENT TO HARM A PROTECTED CLASS
YOU KNOW AND PROSECUTORS DON'T
WANT TO RUN THE RISK OF LOSING A
CASE ARE LOSING ACCOUNT.
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THE EDUCATION
THAT HAS TO GO IN ON THE FRONT
END IN TERMS OF EDUCATING JURORS
ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW A PROTECTED
CLASS IS.
HOW YOU MEASURE INTENDS AND THEN
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE CHARGE
SHOULD BE?
RIGHT SO MY HOPE IS THAT.
IF WE ARE BEGINNING TO INTEGRATE
THIS KIND OF REPORTING.
THAT THAT WILL HELP WITH
EDUCATION ON THE BACKEND FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BECOME BETTER
AWARE ABOUT WHAT DOMESTIC
TERRORISM LOOKS LIKE ABOUT WHAT
THIS DOES NOT FOCUS ON THAT I
KNOW I'M JUST ADDING A LITTLE
EXTRA -- BUT
ABOUT WHAT DOMESTIC TERRORISM
LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT HATE CRIMES
LOOK LIKE SO THAT WE CAN BEGIN
TO ATTACK THE BIAS THAT'S IN OUR
OWN JUDGMENT AS IT RELATES TO
COMING INTO CONTACT WITH THESE
KINDS OF PERPETRATORS.
AND ALSO HOW WE BEGIN TO CHANGE
THE LAWS AS IT RESULTS TO HOW WE
EXACT APPROPRIATE PUNISHMENT FOR
THOSE WHO ARE INVOLVED IN HATE
CRIMES.
BUT I CERTAINLY DON'T THINK THAT
ANYONE SHOULD BE AFRAID TO WALK.
THE STREETS.
BECAUSE OF WHO THEY ARE WHAT
THEY LOOK LIKE THEIR RELIGION
THEIR HERITAGE THEIR COLOR THEIR
GENDER THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
AND BE AFRAID THAT IF SOMETHING
DOES HAPPEN IT WILL NOT BE
APPROPRIATELY REPORTED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
AT THIS BAR QUE IN.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE MISTER TO I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
ALL THE SUPPORTING AS WELL.
AND YOU KNOW ALL ECHO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COME LONGER DOES
COMMENTS THAT WE KNOW HATE
CRIMES ARE ON THE RISE AND THAT
WE NEED TO BE DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN AS A BODY.
TO CHANGE THAT AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS ARE BETTER DECISIONS
AND SO THE ABILITY TO BETTER
COLLECT THIS DATA THROUGH AN
EASIER MECHANISM SEEMS LIKE A NO
BRAINER TO ME.
BUT I THINK THAT WE THEN NEED TO
LOOK DOWN THE LINE TO KNOW THAT
WE AS A BODY NEED TO BE FOCUSED
ON MAKING SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
ARE THE SUBJECT OF THESE KIND OF
CRIMES AND TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT SUPPORT
THIS BILL THAT STRUGGLE WITH
THIS TYPE OF HATRED EVERY DAY
ARE GETTING OUR ATTENTION AND
WE'RE MAKING CALIFORNIA SAFER
AND STRONGER.
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK
[inaudible]
SO.
I HAVE SOME CIVIL LIBERTIES
CONCERNS WITH YOUR BILL.
I AM WORRIED THAT IF SOMEONE'S A
MUSLIM.
DEL AUTOMATICALLY CHECK HATE
CRIME.
AND SINCE WHEN DO WE BELIEVE
THAT AN OFFICER OF THE LAW.
IS JUDGE AND JURY I WOULD FEEL
MUCH [inaudible]
MORE.
SYMPATHETIC IF YOU WOULD SAY
SUSPECTED HATE CRIME.
BUT TO SAY HATE CRIME UP FRONT --
BOTHERS ME --
BECAUSE THAT'S ASKING THE AN
OFFICER TO MAKE A DECISION
THAT'S BEST DONE BY JUDGE AND A
JURY.
I ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WHAT THE
STE SHARES BROUGHT UP.
WHICH IS THAT.
MR CELLS ELLA BROUGHT UP THAT
THERE CAN BE DUPLICATION.
THAT IF THE INFORMATION IS
ALREADY IN THE REPORT WHY DO WE
NEED TO WRITE IT DOWN AGAIN --
SO THOSE ARE TWO CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE IF YOU OR YOUR EXPERTS
COULD ADDRESS THE MIGHT
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
ANY YOU MAY CLOSE AND YOU CAN
ADDRESS ANY OF THOSE QUESTIONS
IN YOUR CLOTHES BREAK THIRD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
COLLEAGUES WILL FOR THE GOOD
QUESTIONS DEFINITELY.
NOT SOLVING OR ELIMINATING ALL
THE OF A HATE CRIME WITH THE WE
NEED MORE EDUCATION YOU KNOW TO
AND TO THE DEPOT TO PUT POLICE
OFFICERS AND EVERYBODY --
IN IN THE A TOOL FOR THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
YOU KNOW FOR THE TWO OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL A REPORT IS NOT
REALLY A DUPLICATE OF THE REPORT.
BECAUSE OF THE IT IS ONLY
REQUIRED TO BUILD THAT REPORT
ONE IS IDENTIFIED.
AS A HATE CRIME.
AND IN AND IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
YOUR CITY IS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DATE IMPLEMENTED THIS PRACTICE.
IN I CAN SHARE WITH YOU MY
EXPERIENCE IN SALES A CITY
COUNCIL WE IMPLEMENTED THIS --
OF THE PRACTICE PUBLIC BACK IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN AND WOULD YOU SEE
THAT THE OF A HATE CRIME.
BEING REPORT MORE ACCURATELY AND
ALSO AND THE REPORT WERE
PROVIDED A DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF
MORE INFORMATION TO PROSECUTE
THE CASE.
SO -- IT IS --
DOUG DEFINITELY HINGE ON THE
TRAINING OF OUR PEACE OFFICERS.
IN I DO I HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
WAS ADDITIONAL TRAINING OF WE
WILL BE.
YOU KNOW ENGINE FOUR TO TO TO TO
THE TO TO THIS DAY WORD --
HEY CRYING CAN BE SURPRISED AND
EARNED AN AND M. MINIMIZED.
SO WHAT WAS THAT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO AT IF YOU
LOOK INTO --
CONCERNING --
MISTER QUICK SECOND POINT ABOUT
THE INFORMATION ON THE STANDARD
FORMS AT THE CENTER FOR AUDITOR
POINTED OUT THAT THAT'S A
WEAKNESS OF THE MEN WHICH IS WHY
WE NEED A SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT.
WHAT ABOUT THE QUOTE I HAVE THE
OTHER QUESTION WAS?
I'M CONCERNED FROM CIVIL
LIBERTIES POINT OF VIEW OF
SOMEONE AUTOMATICALLY CHECKING
HATE CRIME.
WHEN THE PERSON WHEN THE
PERPETRATOR HAPPENS TO BE MUSLIM
OR OF SOME OTHER GROUP THAT?
HAS PRODIGIOUS AGAINST THEM
THAT'S A CONCERN I HAVE WELL I
CERTAINLY CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE
OTHER ANY OTHER GROUPS THAT WE
CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM
SAYING SUSPECTED HATE CRIMES.
ON THE SHOW FOR YOU YOU REALLY
HAVEN'T SEEN THIS IN LA OR SAN
JOSE.
WHERE THESE HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED?
I I DON'T KNOW ABOUT SAN JOSE IN
IN LA WITH THEY HAVE A FORMER
DOESN'T SIX INSPECTED IT TO THE
SKI CRIMES.
AND THE REPORTING DID GO UP WHEN
THEY IMPLEMENTED THAT
[inaudible]
YES BUT DID YOU SEE PREJUDICE IN
WHEN.
THE BOX WAS I CAN'T ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BUT BUT IF IF THERE IS
PREJUDICE THERE THAT'S THIS IS
JUST THE INITIAL REPORT IT'S
REVIEWED BY A SECOND LEVEL IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND THEN BY THE
DA.
THANK YOU AND EARNED INCOME ARE
YOU DON'T KNOW OF ANY CASES WERE
JEWS GO TO THE POLICE.
OR PEACE OFFICER JUST.
CHAPTER TRUCK BOX BECAUSE YOU
YOU CAN INVOLVED WITH SO THE
MOST.
AGAIN ON IT'S REALLY DEPENDING
ON THE TRAINING.
THOSE PEACE OFFICER HAS RECEIVED --
I AM VERY CONFIDENT.
WOULD WITH A GOOD DAY TO YOU OF
THEIR TRAINING DATA CELLS EIGHT
P. DO YOU HAVE TO RECEIVE.
AND I'M HOPING WITH THE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
AND WILL BE YOU KNOW BUT ALL
THOSE WHO APPEARS OFFICERS ALL
BATTERY COULD.
AND NOT TO BUYERS TO BUY JUST
LOOKING AT THE ETHNICITY OF OF
TO YOUR THE PEOPLE EITHER
COMMITTING THE CRIME ALRIGHT.
BEING THE VICTIM DEMONSTRATING --
WHAT I LOVE Là THINK I
UNDERSTAND YOUR YOUR CONCERN
TODAY?
THANK YOU ALTHOUGH DIE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN CLOSE RESPECT THE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND YOU KNOW.
IN A IN A VERY MOST DRIVERS TO
THE STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
A COUNTRY IT IS IMPERATIVE FOR
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO
UTILIZED A FAST.
METHOD TO IDENTIFIED REPORT AND
INVESTIGATE HATE CRIMES AND THE
HATE INCIDENCES.
WAS AB THREE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
CAN CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER.
IN CONDEMNING HATE CRYING AND
PROVIDING EQUAL PROTECTION FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU --
THE MOTION WAS THEIR MOTION OKAY
RECALL FOR ABOUT.
ON AB THREE HUNDRED THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER --
JOHN SIR I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE HI
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SAN DIEGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS WICKS I THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITH
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ALRIGHT WELL.
WHAT MY STAFF BRINGS MY NOTES
DOWN FOR MY BILL --
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE VOTE ONLY --
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB.
ONE THREE SEVEN THIS OFFICER
BILL OF RIGHTS.
OUR REQUIRES THAT A PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICER UNDER
INVESTIGATION BE INFORMED US
SPECIFIC INFORMATION RELATED TO
THE MATTER UNDER INVESTIGATION.
TERRITORY NINE COLD.
IS THERE MOTION [inaudible]
HELLO SECOND.
ON AB ONE THIRTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND.
BARRICADE HAD NO DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE HI
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
I SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO I WICKS.
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PASSES AND
THEN -- Là.
AB FOR ONE ITEM NUMBERS TEEN.
VOTE TO GRANT RECONSIDERATION
ONLY -- AB
FOR ONE FLORA MAKE SPECIFIED
OFFENSES FOR REPEAT D. Y. A
STRAIGHT FAMILY RATHER THAN AN
ALTERNATE FELONY OR MISDEMEANOR
REQUIRES A COURT AFTER SPECIFIED
CONVICTIONS RELATED TO D. Y.. TO
DECLARED A PERSON'S VEHICLE A
NUISANCE AND HAVE IT SEASON SOLD
US BUT CAN I ASK THE CHAIR
QUESTION [inaudible]
SURE.
WHAT IS THE INTENTION HERE IS IT
TO YOU AND ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION BEFORE AND YOU
TELL?
AND IT'S JUST ENOUGH TO OUR
INTEGRATION THANK YOU.
ON A BEFORE WHEN THE MOTION IS
TO GRANT RECONSIDERATION JONES
SAWYER JUMPS ARE AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SAN DIEGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS HI WICKS I AT
THE GRAND [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
ONE THE WINDOW.
THEY MAKE A I HAVE.
OKAY MISTER CHAIR.
WE HAVE A BE A FORTY FOUR YOUR
UP THANK YOU NOW KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF BECAUSE IT'S SO
THAT WE CAN.
GET OUT OF HERE.
AB -- FORTY
FOUR REQUIRES ELIMINATES
MANDATORY CONFINEMENT PERIOD OF
A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS IN THE
COUNTY JAIL AS A RICK.
CHOIR CONDITION BUT A PERSON
SENTENCE FOR TO PROBATION FOR
TESTIFIED CONTROLLED.
SUBSTANCE OFFENSES SPECIFICALLY
WANT THIS BILL WILL ELIMINATE
THE HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY MANDATORY
CONFINEMENT PERIOD FOR A
SENTENCE OF PROBATION ON
CONVICTIONS RELATING TO THE SALE
COCAINE.
COCAINE HYDRO COURT.
HYDRO CHLORIDE DIED OR HEROIN.
TO ELIMINATE THE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAY MANDATORY CONFINEMENT CREATE
FOUR SENTENCE OF PROBATION OR
CONVICTIONS OF FOR TRANSPORT
IMPORTING INTO THE STATE --
SELLING FURNISHING DIMINISHING
OFFERING TO TRANSPORT INTO THE
STATE'S L. FURNACE THE GIVEAWAY
OR ATTEMPT TO IMPORT INTO THE
STATE BASICALLY GIVES JUDGES.
DISCRETION WITH ME TODAY HALF OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ARE NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS. FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT WE
ARE STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
CONFERENCE ATTORNEYS IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE AND ALSO WORKING PUBLIC
DEFENDER OFFICES.
WE HAVE FOUND A LOOKING AT DRUG
LAWS OVER THE LAST TEN TWENTY
THIRTY YEARS IS THAT REALLY BEEN
MULTI MULTIPLE LAYERS THAT HAVE
RESULTED IN EXTENSIVE LITIGATION
FIGHTING OVER.
REALLY HOW OUR DRUG LAWS BE.
IMPLEMENTED I WILL PREVAIL IN
PARTICULAR.
A VERY QUICK THAT IN PARTICULAR
WE HAVE FOUND.
IS THAT --
ROUTE THERE'S BEEN YOU KNOW
STATUTES DEVELOPED. TO KIND OF
FOCUS ON THE OUT LIAR CASES --
SPECIAL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
DRUG POSSESSION OF DRUG
TRAFFICKING OR TRANSPORTATION
THERE'S BEEN THIS KIND OF
IMAGERY OF CARTELS AND KIND OF
THE KIND OF LARGE SUPPLIERS OF
DRUGS.
WHAT WE DON'T RECOGNIZE IN
CALIFORNIA GET RECOGNIZED FOR A
LOT OF YEARS IS THAT OUR LAWS
ALSO APPLY TO THE VERY LOW LEVEL
INDIVIDUAL WHO OFTENTIMES IS
BOTH AN ADDICT AND A VERY SMALL
SUPPLIER?
YET OUR LAWS TREAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS THE SAME --
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO IS HERE IN
THIS COMMITTEE WHERE WE HAD TO
CHANGE.
AND SPECIFY THAT JOB
TRANSPORTATION IS IN POSSESSION.
OF DRUGS FOR PERSONAL USE
BECAUSE THE WAY THAT STATUE WAS
DRAFTED THE CAPTURED ANYBODY WAS
MOVING WITH DRUGS IN THEIR
POSSESSION --
THIS BILL ALSO ADDRESSES THE
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE SEEN ON THE
GROUND ESPECIALLY IN CERTAIN
COUNTIES RURAL COUNTIES.
WHERE LOW LEVEL ADDICTS OR I'M
SORRY ATTICS AND LOW LEVEL DRUG
SUPPLIERS OR THE SAME
INDIVIDUALS IS PART OF THE
INDUSTRY THERE THAT?
THEY ARE NOT THE LARGE SUPPLIERS
THEY'RE NOT THE JUDGE LARGE DRUG
TRAFFICKERS THEY ARE MORE SO
ADDICTS WHO ARE.
SUPPLYING THEIR HABIT IN TRYING
TO FEED THEIR HABIT BY MAKING
MONEY.
WITH THIS BILL DOES IS ALLOW
JUDGES TO LOOK AT THOSE CASES IN
TREAT THOSE CASES IN THAT WAY.
ABSENT THIS BILL THEY HAVE TO
TREAT HIM AS IF THEY ARE LARGE
TRAFFICKERS BECAUSE IS A
MANDATORY MINIMUM.
THIS BILL WOULD REMOVE THAT
MANDATORY MINIMUM GIVE THE
JUDGES THE DISCRETION TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT A MANDATORY OR
INCARCERATION PERIOD SHOULD
APPLY WE SHOULD NOT APPLY --
WHETHER DRUG TREATMENT EXTENSIVE
PROBATION WILL BE MORE EFFECTIVE
FOR THIS CASE. TO THE END OF THE
DAY WITH THIS BILL DOES IS
ENSURE THAT ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS JUDGES CAN --
PARTICULAR ALLIES THE SENTENCE
AND MAKE SURE THAT IN THIS CASE
THE SENTENCE MAKE SENSE FOR THIS
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ON SUPPORT THE BILL.
MORNING MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS LIZZIE DID AND I'M
WITH THE ACLU CALIFORNIA --
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY FOUR WAS STAND WITH THAT
THE COMMENTS OF MISTER HERNANDEZ --
AND IN OF THE I'LL BE BRIEF IT
DOES NOT ELIMINATE A JUDGE'S
ABILITY TO IMPOSE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS GO AND OF
INCARCERATION AS A CONDITION OF
AN OF PROBATION IT MERELY ALLOWS
THEM TO TAILOR.
THE SENTENCE AND TO AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RISKS AND NEEDS TO
THEIR INDIVIDUAL CULPABILITY AND
TO THE SEVERITY IN THE NATURE OF
THE CRIME SO THIS WILL.
MAKE THESE SANCTIONS MORE FAIR
AND IT WILL IMPOSE --
ARE IT WILL IMPROVE OUTCOMES OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
BOTH YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A SECOND DOLLARS FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ME WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THE BUT IN THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS FOR THE FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR HOLD ON WE
DO HAVE.
ONE SO AS I READ IT THERE IS
DISCRETION NOW.
SO HOW DOES THIS DIFFER FROM THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE LAW.
SO YES THERE IS THERE IS THERE
IS VERY LIMITED DISCUSSION IT
HAS TO BE AND I NEED IT
SPECIFIES THAT IT'S AN UNUSUAL
CASES -- AND
SO THERE IT IS SO IT IT'S VERY
LIMITED IN AT A JUDGE'S ABILITY
TO TO MAKE THIS IS TERMINATIONS
AND SO --
AND THAT THERE IS IN A NUMBER OF
FACTORS CURRENT DETERMINATION
THAT ARE VERY NARROW --
AND SO THIS WOULD BROADEN THAT
DISCRETION IT WOULD ALLOW THEM
IT CHANGES IF SERVER CURRENTLY
SAYS SHALL UNLESS THEY'RE THESE
UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCES IT WOULD
CHANGE IT TO TO A MAY SO WOULD
BROADEN THE AMOUNT OF DISCRETION
AT THE HALF.
DO SHALL MAKE THINGS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
TERRY MCAULIFFE RESPECT FAST
FREE AYE VOTE.
OKAY ONE CALL FROM --
WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY THE ANSWER GO AHEAD THIS
CALL FOR QUESTION ON AB FORTY
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
LACKEY I'M SORRY NO.
ALMOST GOT YOU [inaudible]
LACKEY NO.
BAUER-KAHAN HI BAUER-KAHAN I
DEEP NO.
NO KAMLAGER-DOVE IT WAS A SET UP
MR LACKEY I WAS WORK
KAMLAGER-DOVE I QUIRK.
HI QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS HI WICKS I
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ONE HAS BEEN DONE SETS WITH.
ITEM TWO WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM THREE WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE BARRICADE HAND
ON EIGHTY FOUR FOUR FIVE HI.
BAUER-KAHAN I SANTIAGO ON AB
[inaudible]
FOUR FOUR FIVE SANTIAGO NO.
I DON'T KNOW --
SIX WAS JUST DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER NINE WAS ON CONSENT
ITEM TEN ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO SANTIAGO.
ON AB FIVE EIGHTY TWO ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible]
ELEVEN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
ON RECONSIDERATION.
ON RECONSIDERATION I ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM THIRTEEN ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B. SIX
OH SEVEN BY MISS CARILLO
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN ON CONSENT.
I AND NUMBER.
SIXTEEN HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH.
AN ITEM NUMBER. SEVENTEEN HAS
BEEN DISPENSED WITH.
THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU